little the red light comes on when
okay
h
but we've normally been been uh doing so
I just turned on my microphone as you
can
tell okay so so our first bill we're
going to hear today is HB
1029 it has to do about the clamont
police
commission and
uh and today we have representative
uh before you begin representative let
role
Pres
here
yeah
here thank you
Mr representative the floor is yours
thank you Mr chair thank you fell
representative uh I'm presenting HB 1029
plan monce commission I apologize that
you this may all look somewhat familiar
that uh last year we had hp88 that
passed but um this section apparently
was lost and uh was not brought forth
during that uh hp88 and was not
discovered until after through the
governor so I apologize for having to
come back to do some housekeeping and uh
have this uh
added so that the council who again just
appointed their first police
commissioner last
night also has the power her to have a
hearing and
remove so uh is any anybody you want to
turn turn it over to to speak
additionally to the bill I have uh my
co-sponsors here if they wish to speak
like I said it's more of just
housekeeping
and do the co-p sponsors wish to step up
and
speak
okay
okay yes understand I understand uh just
to keep our record straight could you
identify yourself as a clerk
sorry um again I'm okay the mic is on
right you can everybody hear me all
right I'm state representative John
cluder Sullivan County District 10
representing the entire city of
Claremont and I am I'm a co-sponsor of
the bill I am actually have a few more
terms than representative o' Hearn and I
sort of I know it was a goof on my part
too because I I agreed to sponsor the
bill on behalf of the city but I
probably should have read it a little
more thoroughly and I assume the issue
was covered but uh so I didn't catch it
and none of the other co-sponsors and it
went through I guess I don't know this
committee
and Senate didn't catch it and uh also
OLS I'm surprised you know I'm not I
think they do a great job don't get me
wrong it just and again the governor
even you know that I figured they might
have raised the issue before signing it
but no one caught it it was one of those
Goose that just went through the system
and I'll take my fair share of the blame
but it just reminds me constantly
and in my own committee Public Works
those things happen I've been around
long enough to know it's just those
things happen and you just got to do the
best you correct it and this bill as
filed by representative oarn and the
rest of the sponsors just uh you know
our intent to correct it and make clear
what the intent was that the members of
the city council could not only appoint
but dismiss members of the police
commission in the original bill which I
believe was House Bill 88 which your
committee approved last last year and
put on I believe the consent calendar
that was our intent and we go you know
we goofed up and uh those things happen
but it's an an honest attempt and the C
majority of the city council wants this
so we are trying to carry out their
intent of what they want thank you
represent you're welcome the I have a
question this made it all the way to the
consent calendar I believe I mean I
can't remember I believe it was on the
cons or consent calendar last year you
know what you remember the vote I I
believe it was unanimous I mean
represent it was unanimous so and I I
think I assume it was this committee uh
unanimous and went to and passed and
went to the house as I said nobody C
caught it you know and I'm not trying to
pin the blame because I I have to take
my fair share of the blame too being
around here but it's just one of those
things and it's happened to me before I
made goof I've seen other
Representatives who've been in as long
have made goose
as far as you know it didn't make it to
the legislative
floor well it was on the I think the
consent calendar so I mean could we have
could have been scrutinized better I
suppose it's possible we just all and
I'll take my share we all goofed and
this is just a way to to correct that
goof
please calendar on the house
andar okay thank
you
okay so I don't I don't know any other
questions I think repr
oarn very clarified it very well
representative cludy could I ask you to
fill out a p card okay yes I will do
that Mr chairman thank you and I'm sorry
but I wasn't sure you know what the the
way the hearing
is okay uh let me open it up to the the
members of the committee anybody have
any
questions for the
sponsors
yes uh could I ask a question of the
since we appear to be in the cleanup
mode uh I noticed that the uh the bill
States
specifically that uh the council should
have full power to remove any police
commissioner do you think there is any
requirement for the uh Council to remove
any other
Commissioners uh you mean at the moment
representative as as as a matter of uh
practice um I of course I'm not a me
repr heard might be better he's on the
city council too and I I want to be
careful it's but I think they want the
authority to appoint and remove police
Commissioners more for the future there
I don't think there is any as far as I
know any Police Commissioner they are
dissatisfied with as of today but I
can't be sure of that uh but I think
they want this power uh and this they
they voted to request this of the state
representatives from Claremont to file
this bill to take care of because it's
right now state law and uh and basically
so we are we members of The Claremont
delegation you know the four reps and
Senator filed this bill at the request
of our city council and filed the
previous Bill last year House Bill 88
follow up yes uh the reason I asked the
question is the title of the the section
is removal of Commissioners it doesn't
say removal of police Commissioners
right and but the the the text in the
the section is specific to police
Commissioners which is why I ask do you
the Claremont Town Council actually
wants the permission to remove any
Commissioners I I I think they if if
it's in their judgment I believe as the
text says it's any time for and it's got
to be a Just Cause And after due hearing
um but I think they want that Authority
it's more for in the future uh more than
anything I do I'm not aware of any
commissioner that they are dissatisfied
the moment they if this bill passes and
becomes law that they would remove at
this time that's my understanding
represent something you like to add to
that maybe he
can if you could swing the in your
direction thank you Mr chair you can
hear me so right
now the city manager was you pointing
authority to a police commission uh all
the other committees and commissions
that are in the city are are appointed
by the council and we can remove a
member of any board or
committee thank you very
much thank you are there any other
questions from the from the uh Comm Mr
chair
yes um I think this is kind of a general
question but does the State of New
Hampshire have policies and procedures
that
governs how a city or in the case of
smaller municipalities
towns uh deal with committees and
commissions is there any standard that's
set um it would seem to me that if there
was a hole in the procedures for
Claremont
perhaps other cities have exactly the
same issue and I'm just wondering if the
state has anything that governs the
relationship between City councils and
thank you m shair there is rsas that
govern uh police commissions and other
municipalities uh clamont is is unique
it was actually the first police
commission uh in the state therefore um
you go back to the uh the first uh time
it was uh
amended I I said it's existed way before
the rsas we're just a little bit unique
to the police commission that ours
existed and and has to come to the
legislative body and there has some has
been some discussion talk about
incorporating it to others but at the
end of the day
clont like every other community has
their un uniqueness and we like just to
keep this because we don't do it that
often coming for you legisl except for
this term
twice to rectify uh this change thank
you that
any other comments
yes thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so I just I come from
a small town so I don't know what the
makeup is of in clar could you tell me
how many City uh Commissioners they have
and how many are on the U uh you call
them the uh how many Commissioners you
have three uh police Commissioners three
of each three police commissioners
to make up their the commission and then
again they set policies and procedures
in hire and fire of the uh clma police
department to include the
chief thank you thank you Mr chairman
from seeing none thank you both for
representing the uh this issue before us
for for clont and we'll have an
executive on this in about two
weeks thank you Mr chair thank you thank
committee
here okay that will'll end the uh the
hearing on HB 1029 and we are in
uh uh temporary recess until uh the time
for HP 1046 to come up before us which
minutes I'm
sorry yeah I didn't bring my gav with me
so I have
G so please relax we can't start the
hearing until
9:30 so if you want to go use the the
do
for
l
comp
would
position
other
don't
we
he
committee work
committee
basically
thank you Mr
chair for the record my name is Linda t
tner I'm representative for Sullivan
District 9 and that's the towns of
planfield Cornish Grantham Cen
Springfield sunap Newport Community
about half the county um I was asked by
a constituent uh The Honorable Virginia
wiwin who emailed a letter to uh this
committee to each and every one and I
also have a copy I'll leave for the
clerk um she sent her testimony and this
is why I've submitted the bill uh she
was a house representative several years
ago and decided to run for County
Commissioner uh we have three districts
in Sullivan County and sullan county is
one of the um least populated counties
in the State uh and we have three major
municipalities cities I guess you'd call
them uh Claremont Newport and
Charlestown are probably our three major
areas um but when we come to election
for the County Commissioners uh it's an
at large vote everybody in the County
votes for the commissioner that comes up
in whatever
District um and that has several
disadvantages um one is that even though
um you represent a district and you live
in a district you may not be known and
and if you're known for example in
Claremont for some reason um you have
access to a lot more votes than in your
District um another issue is that that
it's fairly expensive to run a
campaign uh countywide we we're very
rural and so you know you're traveling
uh just in my district it takes me an
hour and a half to uh make a trip to
each of the polling places on Election
Day so you can see that and since I have
just the upper part of the county um it
takes a lot of effort a lot of time and
a lot of money uh to run for County
Commissioner um it also seems in my mind
very illogical that you would set up
districts and then not have the person
who represents that District be elected
exclusively from the people within the
district so that that person is a true
representative of the district um so I
took the uh bill that came before the uh
committee I believe u i don't know a cou
last term maybe uh for Carol County um
and uh worked with OLS on it and you
will see that it's a bill that actually
um changes changes the voting to
districts but does it in a in a u over a
period of time as the Commissioners uh
have um different terms terms that
expire at different times so it would it
would slowly come into as they run for
their new election I also think it's a
great time to do it because because
we're redistricting everybody so it's
kind of um the electorate will be kind
of confused I think this first uh
election just by you know everybody's
going to be in a different District or a
lot of districts are going to change so
that's kind of U my little Spiel for
today and I'm open to any questions
thank you uh thank you representative
has any thought been given to changing
the term of the uh no the terms are the
same it's just that they um expire it
they're staggered so they expire at
different times so this bill is written
to um you know to the to the staggered
elections of those people thank you any
committee
yes thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my
question uh
on line nine of the bill it says of the
Commissioners so chosen one shall you
serve a four-year term and one she'll
serve a two-year
term how do you determine which one of
the Commissioners or the the people
running for the uh
uh the office of uh commissioner will be
the four-year term and which will be the
two-year term these are these are the
staggered terms that they have now so
it's it's to um it speaks to them with
their staggered terms coming into that
in other words one term one term will
expire now which will go four years
another term will expire in two years
and and that person will get elected so
it it nears their staggered their
already staggered um
terms so uh representative so it might
ass assume that after a few years
everybody's on a twoe everybody's on yes
everybody is then back on on schedule
yes any more
questions yes I have a followup but it
really doesn't your answer really
doesn't
explain
how of the two Commissioners that are
up how the one will be chosen for a
two-year
term there's there's three Commissioners
in suin County that have staggered
elections okay and so one of
them will um come in as of this year one
of them will be midway through his his
or her
term oh all right that explains it thank
you that
make
yes thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question representative this
is really a nitpicky kind of editorial
question and and it has to do with the
the choice of the words Chosen and
qualified uh
and as the bill is talking about
election I wonder why you chose you
chose the word chosen instead of elected
I I didn't choose it that's part of the
issue it I don't know if it's language
that um mir's language and statutes uh
OS um that would be something that ol
would have to speak to I think or I
would have to ask them I'm not sure why
that's like that I you know I assumed it
was um the language that we see
sometimes in statutes that that come
from way way way back so right I I guess
it would be clearer to me if it were
consistently worded throughout that you
know these these folks are elected not
chosen okay which is quite a different
thing and and also the use of the word
qu
qualified um I W wonder if that might be
confusing I think the qualified speaks
to the fact that they are resident of
the
district so it doesn't it doesn't mean
that one they're seated their
qualification doesn't mean once they're
seated it means something different well
I think uh qualified for if you run for
office to qualify there's C there's a
statute around that and since this bill
is dealing with uh districts and up to
this point you had to be from the
district but you were elected at large
by the county um I think it just speaks
to to being qualified as being still
from that District I see thank you very
much representative
Guthrie thank you Mr Speaker and thank
you for taking my question and welcome
Happy New Year uh
I'm I'm not clear but I'm pretty sure I
you've already answered the question is
it my understanding that this results
the current system you have now results
in a representative from each district
so there isn't any District that doesn't
have a representative as far
as where they live right so you're not
trying to do that you're just saying
that it's in cumbersome to run
the whole uh County when you're only
representing a third of the county is
that that correct so would be it's an
efficiency thing as much as anything
right so for example mine is a floal
obviously with as many the eight towns
that I have um if I were a commissioner
I might represent those eight towns but
everybody in Sullivan County would vote
have to have to vote for me um and all
these towns that I represent except
Newport and even newport's probably one
of the smaller town smaller definitely
smaller than Claremont um so if if I
were to run at large and somebody who
lived near the border of Claremont who
worked in Claremont and um had a lot of
connections with Claremont obviously has
a decided advantage over anybody that
lives in these other towns um so you
know I I think um suvin is only one of
three counties that that still does this
and I think when New Hampshire was
formed and it was all very rural and it
was very spread out um it you know
probably this system worked where you
had an at large voting for any
commissioner regardless of what district
they're in but now we're at a point um
in population and size that it needs to
be changed and it needs to be changed so
that if you're in District One and you
represent for example the eight towns
that I
represent um not only am I from those
Town one of those towns but that the
constituents in those towns the voters
in those towns are the people that elect
me not the people in Langdon or aworth
or Claremont or Charlestown so um that's
what the whole reason for this is uh we
don't do it any other way you know we
don't do it with state representatives
we don't do it with state senators we
don't even do it with like Selectmen and
school boards that you know you run for
Selectmen in Newport and Claremont gets
to vote on it um so I I think that's
that it makes sense and uh like I said I
think this is a way to stagger it in so
that uh you know everybody that's
present commissioner gets to fill out
their term and then as the election goes
yes I'm wondering if there's a map
available showing um showing the
boundaries of these districts well it's
it's just been
redistricted uh we've just gone through
redistricting so I'm sure there's a new
map somewhere of U of of the county um
Commissioners districts uh I don't have
it right handy with me today but I'm
sure it's online could you have it sent
John um I I only was in contact with one
um and he said that uh as far as he was
concerned it it really didn't make a
difference to him he thought it would
save him a lot of money running um the
John cluder who was here before uh said
he got in contact with one of the other
Commissioners who responded the same way
that uh he was uh thought it would be
more efficient and thought it would be a
lot less money from him that he would
have to raise in
campaign any other comments
yes uh thank you uh Mr chairman um I
just have I think maybe one or possibly
two question the um
currently it's one person
in the district do they live in that
District currently um for example I live
in sunap so I ran in that I was able to
run in that District uh the
Commissioners are basically the same
thing it's dividing the county up into
three district and you must live in in
that particular District in order to run
but when you run and and they're terms
are staggered but when you run uh you
the whole county has to vote on you
uh so you're you're running at large
through the whole County a follow just
one quick hit so just to clarify that
means that no commissioner that's in
office now could be um pushed out based
on this decision right right no the only
thing that would push them out is if the
redistricting push them
out any other questions from the
committee oh I'm sorry yes
please thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question
just curious if you know of any
problems uh um in the current with the
current system and by problems I mean
not what this might solve but have there
been any issues uh in the past that you
know about uh where the where you can
cite a
problem I would say uh there there isn't
necessarily a problem um I've looked at
the commissioner's uh elections for the
past few
terms and it and it seems like they're
in a um they're from an area that's
fairly close to this Claremont
Charlestown Newport triangle um that
even though the dist even though they're
in their own Districts The District
wherever that District comes close to
the the other ones in that particular
trajectory that's where they seem to get
elected and that's been the experience
of um a couple of people who've run from
you know from Outer Ling areas so um I
think that's another thing just and it
and it may be coincidence you know but
it seems like when you vote at large
like that that that tend tends to happen
I think the fact that seven other
counties in the state run their
elections by District um and there's
only three that that um don't uh
Sullivan's one of them and the three are
rural counties uh I think that's that
speaks to the fact that voting by
district and electing by District Works
in other
counties you're welcome any other
committee thank you representative thank
you and I'll send up my written
testimony and also a copy of uh the
letter that Virginia wrote to all of
much next uh we have commentary from uh
Kate
hgan from the New Hampshire Association
of
counties welcome good morning uh Mr
chairman and members of the municipal
and County government committee my name
is Kate Morgan I'm representing the New
Hampshire Association of counties in
this case I am representing the Sullivan
County Commissioners who are opposed to
this bill they are very happy with the
current system they believe that it is
important that every member of the
county because Sullivan County is a
small County gets to vote on the County
Commissioners decisions at the county
level as you all know are not made by a
district position they are made
countywide therefore the Commissioners
would ask that you oppose this bill um
because they are a small community and
feel that every voter should have a say
in who is elected to their County
Commission and I happy to take any
questions that you may have this morning
committee
yes thank you very much for taking my
question um what if if you believe that
County Commissioners representing a
district can be elected by anyone in
that county what's the purpose of having
a
district um across the county from a
of town cities so that way
representation is given from across the
county
representative okay follow up Mr
chairman thank you so if if the purpose
of the district is to provide
representation why would you be opposed
to voters in that District rep voting
for their representative why have other
people outside the district vote for
that representative uh the S count
County Commissioners believe that it is
a fair system for everyone in the county
to vote for their Commissioners so that
uh because decisions are made at a
countywide level and not made at a
district level okay thank you any other
sorry thank you for taking my question
how many Commissioners are there thank
you representative there are three
Commissioners for every county in the
state for total 30 across the state
three are from Sullivan County followup
Mr chairman yes please are all three
Commissioners opposed to the bill yes
sir they
are thank you any other comments yes
representative G thank you Mr chairman
thank you for your testimony uh I you
see the lettera is from the New
Hampshire Association of counties and
it's signed by a number of uh County
Commissioner chairman uh are they
advocating is the uh Association of
counties advocating that all the
counties use this
system thank you representative G three
no they are not this is just our
letterhead for the association of
counties and we list our officers on
there that's why they're listed at the
top we are only making comments on this
particular particular bill for suvin
County today thank you for your
testimony yes
representa thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my
question I guess my question is a
followup to the previous question which
is if you believe that the current
system is
fair then I infer that you believe the
syst in being used by Seven Counties is
currently unfair why are you not then
advocating for a change in the way
elections are held in the O in the
majority of counties sure thank you
representative I would tell you that
each county in the state is different
there are 10 and we like to joke that
there are 10 different ways to do
absolutely everything the Sullivan
County Commissioners believe that this
current system that they have is what
County
follow thank you very much any other
committee seeing
none thank you Miss forgan thank you is
there is there any other comments from
bill seeing none we'll end the uh the
sorry Walter steton I'm sorry my mistake
please uh please come
Stapleton thank you Mr chair and members
of the committee Walt Stapleton Sullivan
County District 5 Claremont Ward
three um I'm not going to repeat the
testimony uh of the the prior previous
speaker here uh so I'm going to save
some time as much as possible but I'm
briefly uh if uh of the mind if it ain't
broke don't fix it um this has been a
longstanding tradition the way we've
done it in Sullivan County we've got a
good Sullivan County Commissioners team
um do the business very well and uh
residents seem to be very satisfied with
the way we've done business and electing
Commissioners for the past several years
so uh I'm I'm for the um at large uh
County um system that we have and it
works and U I think we should keep it so
I'm opposed to the
bill any questions from the committee to
Mr to representative
state representative apologize for
trying to skip over you earlier that's
all right was not meant that way all
right I don't see any further
youon since there are no uh further
questions on this bill I'm going to uh
end the the uh testimony on House Bill
1046 we will begin our next testimony at
so those of you who want to use the
minutes
I
don't but you will
she
your
basketball
okay how old is
plent
basketball
course
okay
spe
what's
s
in
yes thank thank you Mr chair and members
of the committee uh this is a
housekeeping bill I believe in
um was presented to us for one
particular County last year um and in
looking at the RSA saw that Boro County
and Rockingham County had similar uh uh
competitive build bidding um rules and
so I felt it was better to make this the
same for all counties it's a common
sense way to get an effective um price
for your county and watch your budget
um and I think that um it serves the
purpose of uh making sure that every
county is operating the same way so that
there are no surprises I when we were
when I was doing the research on the on
the original Bill last year and saw that
two particular counties had been called
out the question is why why does that
not um affect every County or why is
this not a good tool for every County so
that's why I went ahead and submitted
this bill for All Counties as opposed to
time that's it thank you there is there
any other Miss hgan do you have
additional
Gilman good morning again Mr chairman
and members of the municipal and County
government uh committee my name is Kate
Morgan I represent the New Hampshire
Association of counties and this time I
am here on behalf of all 10 counties in
particular in this case your county
administrators uh the association is
opposed to this bill while we understand
what the representative is attempting to
do you will note that I said in my last
testimony that there are 10 counties and
they each do things 10 different ways so
requiring Coos who has a very different
structure than Hillsboro to take
competitive bidding in the same way when
they may not have the same support staff
available able could be very challenging
for some of the smaller counties that's
why you'll notice in the statute the two
bigger counties with the largest staffs
have these competitive bidding rules uh
so the association would ask that you
oppose the bill today and I am happy to
take any questions that the committee
has does the committee have any
questions for Miss
wargan yes uh CH thank you Mr chairman
and thank you for your testimony uh I
just took a quick look at 28a and that
in 28a it says that the Commissioners
have the right to wave the need for
competitive bidding there's some details
that they have to go through as far as
reporting are concerned but is is my
understanding this bill takes away the
the county commissioner's uh ability to
wave the need for competitive bidding I
read it that way yes representative
thank you right thank
represa
so
um earlier this term we had another bill
related to competitive building bidding
by counties and it was just for Carol
County um if I yeah if I'm remembering
correctly um and I believe we rejected
it because we didn't want
to take an action that was just specific
to one County we want to do something
broader so are you saying that we should
have actually passed that one instead I
cannot make any comments on why this
body voted the way that it
did well did did you testify on the
previous Bill the Carol County bill I
did
follow well play
Miss
yes
thank you for taking my question
um some of us here on the committee are
also Selectmen and City councilors and
so forth I know in our case we have a
competitive bidding process for our town
but there's an exception given for the
state bid
price and looking through this B bill I
don't see that exception being part of
it um and so I'm wondering if that's an
oversight
or I am unsure representative you would
probably need to ask representative
bill representative
Guth I'm sorry representative
Melvin
microphone
representative thank you for taking my
question on line 28 section three it
says the award of a purchase is made
other than the lowest bidder a unanimous
vote of the Commissioners are required
why is
that again I would probably direct that
R mdon your microphone thank you there
we go um I'm I'm trying to understand
what the problem is by competitive
bidding why why is that an issue with
the
counties I my opinion is that there is
not an issue the two largest counties
have in statute a uh a competitive
bidding process and that makes sense for
them because they are are the two
largest counties smaller counties like
Coos and belnap do not have the same
resources that say Hillsboro OR
Rockingham might have so to subject them
to the same standards that Hillsboro and
Rockingham have could provide additional
burden on the counties and I would argue
could result in having to expend some
additional funds to hire staff to
accomplish
that follow follow up yes what do your
your group recommend how are we supposed
to control the competitive bidding
process of the Commissioners how do we
ensure that they do it at a certain
amount without a statute so there there
is a uh there is each county has a
policy on what is appropriate um and I
believe that your county delegation and
as a member of that County delegation
you have the right to weigh in on that
policy can I quote you on that sure okay
thank you
than you thank you representa there any
more comments from the committee
yes thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my
question by your um reasoning I'm sorry
representative stavis I'm sorry quite
all right by your reasoning isn't it
also possible that because of a lack of
competitive bidding that those countries
least able to pay for certain types of
services over
$5,000 might be getting charged more
than other counties who are doing
competitive bidding unless result in
higher expenses for their citizens thank
you representative I would argue that
each County does do competitive bidding
they just don't have a
formal statute of law that tells them
how to do it each county has a policy on
how they are going to do competitive
bidding so it's not like they aren't
doing it it's just it's not a formal
statute
yes follow up go ahead so if they are
already doing it then what would be the
problem with a uniformity of doing it I
would say the problem would be resources
representative because these smaller
counties don't have the resources that a
hill store or Rockingham would
have thank you yes represent M thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question giving given all that you've
said do you see any um issues do you
take any issue with the considerations
that are listed here as being uh
reasonable for a county to follow in in
considering a qualified bidder I would
want to take that back to the county
administrators but I'm happy to do that
and bring that back to the committee
thank you thank you representa any other
committee seeing none is are there any
is there anybody else that would like
bill
no no our our procedures have it that
when a representative introduces a bill
finished Mr chair we had representative
twice
well I think in this case uh what we can
do we can ask representative Gilman can
provide input but can't testify is that
to you can answer questions but you
can't offer a
testimon is that is that unclear enough
for
the the reason that there's a little
confusion here is because we do have
a a rule in the house that when a
representative
testifies before a committee if they're
on that committee they have to step
aside for the balance of the uh
committee rejoin the committee during
executive session for all the questions
and answers so we're in a little bit of
uh soft ground here but go ahead in the
in the interest of providing more
information to our
committee you want to ask your question
or is there just an answer you want I
just wanted an answer to give um thank
you Mr chair um uh representative lel's
asked about the uh bidding for uh State
procurement and that is under Section
seven it doesn't require going through
competitive building it's on
10 yes representative Matt you I I I
think this will fit into what you are uh
saying Mr chair and thank you Mr chair
and thank you representative for taking
my question
online I got to go to this
it says if the award for the purchase is
made to other than the lowest
bidder is that supposed to read lowest
bidder or should that say lowest
responsible bidder as has been noted
previously I'm just curious if that's an
OSS mistake or if that's intentional and
you don't need to speak to the intent
because I'll understand if if it's
written simple answer is yes okay thank
you representative Melvin you have
addition comment yes uh thank you and
thank you for taking my question in
reference
to uh
283 if an award of a purchases made to
other than the lowest bidder and enous
vote by the County Commission is
why
well I think the concern is
um of a disagreement between whether
lowest bid is qualified from um all the
other in the list that um the the odd
man out or odd person out um needs to
convince the other two uh Commissioners
that going with other than the less
bitter lowest bidder which is
budgetarily um important
needs to to explain why that one is not
necessarily A best bit for the project
purchased thank you thank you
representative any other further
questions from the
audience well from the committee seeing
none I'd like to uh end the uh hearing
on House Bill
chair okay just so uh you may uh not
realize but the uh the cafeteria is open
today which it hasn't been in a long
time so when we hit the lunch period if
any of you want to use the cafeteria it
will be open uh in preparation for this
meeting some of you have requested a a
slightly longer lunch so that you can
complete some of your cross committee
assignments uh do anybody have any input
directly to me of of when you want that
lunch to start and end so that we can
accommodate you if you if you have any
issues I was planning on a on a
uh around and one hour lunch around one
o'clock that fit what you're looking to
do yes um Mr chairman I just want to
give notice that I have to introduce
aill 3 P.M in judiciary okay do you
anticipate that we'll we'll work up
until 3 or at our current rate I think
we'll be done by three okay thank you
all okay so uh we are in uh recess until
uh
10:30
Mr chairman concerning your announcement
about the cafeteria does that does that
imply that lunch is on you yes it does
imply that but you know all you got to
do is tell the uh the lady at the
register and she'll take care of it it's
is
e
thank you
chairman uh good morning chairman Dolan
and members of the House County and
municipal government committee for the
record my name is Matt Wilhelm I proudly
represent Hillsboro County District 42
covering Manchester ws one2 and three in
the New Hampshire house which covers the
queen City's historic Mard downtown and
Northend neighborhoods colleagues I'm
here today to introduce House Bill 1275
it's an act relative to Municipal
representation on Regional planning
commissions with the bipartisan Federal
infrastructure investment and jobs Act
of 20121 signed into law and in the
anticipation of over1 billion dollar in
federal funds becoming available to the
state of New Hampshire in the coming
decade I filed this bill as an attempt
to bring more Equitable representation
to the cities of Manchester and nashwa
on their respective Regional planning
commissions currently uh every
municipality in the state of New
Hampshire regardless of population uh
gets at least two Representatives on
their Regional Planning Commission a
third representative is added for each
town with a population between 10 and
25,000 and a fourth rep is allocated for
municipalities with more than 25,000
residents but that's where the statutory
formula ends House Bill 1275 as drafted
filed and presented today proposes one
representative for each municipality and
an added an additional representative
for each additional 10,000 residents in
theory the legislation is simple
relatively straightforward and addresses
my concern of an inequitable formula for
representation after the LSR was posted
I received an email from leadership at
the southern New Hampshire Regional
Planning Commission to ask for a meeting
and I welcome the opportunity to receive
feedback and through a series of
conversations with regional planning
commissions uh and staff from across the
state I crafted an amendment which
addresses unintended consequences of my
bill as drafted does the committee have
a copy of that Amendment uh no we don't
okay I'm G to pass around both the
testimony
I would ask the uh the committee to
maintain a copy of the
amendment to perhaps be implemented at
review and so with a commitment to
listening learning and finding common
ground I'm also pleased to present uh
Amendment
0037 which is being circulated right now
it's an effort to address the concerns I
heard from the Regional planning
commissions namely decreasing smaller
towns Baseline representation from two
seats to only one and increasing
Manchester's repr representation from
four seats to 10 that was that's what's
in the original Bill the amendment
addresses uh that so instead this
amendment it keeps Town's Baseline
representation at two seats a third seat
for municipalities over 10,000 residents
and a fourth seat
for municipalities over 25,000 residents
but it also adds a series of steps for
larger towns and cities adding an
additional rep at 45,000 residents
70,000 residents and finally 100,000
residents these steps increase
progressively with a rep being added
after the addition of 10,000 residents
then 15,000 20,000 25,000 and finally
30,000 residents above the previous
here something I learned through these
conversations is the strong Spirit of
regional cooperation between communities
on each Planning Commission there is
concern about unintended consequences of
big fish taking over small ponds so I
took that feedback into account as I uh
as I took a look at the formula uh
committed to keeping smaller communities
whole while making modest strides for
cities with more than 60,000 residents
by giving them a few extra seats at the
table the net impact of the amendment
increases nashua's representation from
four seats to six seats and Manchester's
representation from four seats to seven
seats on their Regional Planning
Commission in short Amendment 0037 it's
a goodfaith compromise aimed at
addressing concerns raised by the
regional planning commissions while
staying true to the intent of this
legislation which is to provide our
states to larger cities my home town of
nasua and the community I now represent
Manchester with more proportional and
Equitable representation I urge the
committee members to send House Bill
1275 to the house floor with a strong
bipartisan ought to pass as amended
recommendation and I welcome your
questions thank you first question is
the is amendment
that litigated through
OS it was submitted through OLS yes okay
so that that amendment can be considered
at exective session yes thank you thank
you any questions from the committee
yes thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
this is a kind of a scam setting
question if you will can you describe to
me the kinds of inequities that may
result and possibly do result in
Regional planning commissions with where
proportional presentation such as you're
proposing in this bill is not present
what are the kinds of things that you
see happening that would be negative
should this not pass it's a great
question and thank you for it I
appreciate it one thing I want to be
really clear about is this is not about
writing a wrong this is about
anticipating more than a billion dollars
in federal funding to our state in the
coming decade and
I think that you know I I'm I'm an
advocate for the constituents that I
represent I have you know at every every
opportunity I'm looking to make sure
that Manchester has uh you know a full
seat at the table it is unclear to me
what the uh debates might be at Regional
planning commissions over the course of
the next decade but I do want to make
sure that Manchester uh has has better
representation than that they have now
giving their proportional population so
it's unclear it's it's I can't
anticipate what those debates are going
to be or what the issues are going to be
um but in the same way that uh looking
at the you know redistricting proposal
for example um Manchester was allocated
32 seats while other proposals had 33 or
34 seats on in the house map um and so
those those are concerning as a a
representative of
Manchester
yes thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question so
in preparation for this hearing I
studied the language of the bill and my
understanding um as the bill is written
is currently representation is
proportional based on population my
concern would be that I I understand
your your rationale or argument but my
concern is and would you agree that the
the the bill and then the subsequent
Amendment would therefore increase the
influence of larger Towns at the expense
of smaller towns with your proposal to
increase
representation um in the larger cities
perhaps specifically Manchester would
you agree with that
in would you agree that's that's what
the bill is doing thank you uh thank you
for the question
representative
uh I want to be careful about that
particular characterization of the bill
and I think the attempt in the amendment
is to not decrease the representation of
any municipality as it stands now but
simply add additional tiers and
additional seats for those larger
municipalities um so I the the goal is
not to decrease representation for for
anybody you know the amendment really uh
tries to increase
representation uh for the cities of
nashille and
Manchester follow y followup so yes I
understand that
but the point being is that the result
of that while you're trying to increase
representation the effect of that would
be that it decreases representation of
smaller towns because as you scale you
know you're you're you're decreasing
representation that that's
representative I ask you to try to form
question W would you agree that the
result of of um the content of the bill
would be that the
towns
uh I I think that's one way to look at
you thank you Mr chairman thank you for
your testimony um I'm sort of aren't
that knowledgeable I'm a selectman and
maybe I should be but uh could you tell
me what kind of votes that's where the
power is how what kind of votes the
commission would make would make
particularly regarding uh federal funds
coming into the
area yes thank you representative for
the question uh you know I think there
there will be sums of money that will be
allocated to the regional planning
commissions and it will be up to them to
decide how that money is
allocated um within within that region
um uh and so I think there's some
representatives from uh from Regional
planning commissions that that might be
able to speak to that in anticipation of
some of those the funds becoming
available
um but that's that's that's it you know
that's very much the purpose of the bill
it's an anticipation of the uh
investment thank thank you for your
yep
um each each Planning Commission has a
different number based on the number of
municipalities that are part of that
Regional Planning Commission um this is
a net
increase
um of four
seats sorry of two seats for
nsha and three additional seats for
Manchester on their their respective
planning commissions and they're in
commissions
know uh if I might representative when I
think about the the Brilliance of our
Founders uh in establishing a 400 member
House of
Representatives um I think I I just I
think there's a lot of wisdom and a lot
of um you know it's incredible to be to
be able to have that kind of
representative democracy in our state
um the way the Caps are set up on the
regional planning commissions at this
time
um makes me as a resident of Manchester
uh feel like we're not getting our our
full seat at the table and so um you
know this is a this is an attempt to get
a little bit closer to that we know we
won't be nearly as close as the uh the
way it's broken down in the New
Hampshire house for example um but it's
a step towards uh better representation
for the bigger
questions hi so I represent conquered
which is the third largest city after
Manchester and nashaa so um
if I'm understanding the formulas
correctly here um its representation
would be unchanged in both the unamended
and amended Bill and as it currently is
for Representatives either
way uh thank you representative for the
question uh I'd have to take another
look at the original bill but under the
amendment conquer's representation would
stay the
another um so
um one thing I like about the unamended
version is that it's future proof so
if we
someday have a city in New Hampshire
with say a million residents or whatever
um their representation will
automatically be adjusted to be
proportional to their population but
with the amended
version um it seems we we would have to
with the amended version we would have
to um keep coming back to add new tiers
whenever cities grow certain amounts to
um
continue uh keeping it proportional is
that
correct under under the formula in the
date we would not have to update the
formula until we get over any
municipality is over
135,000 residents that would be the next
that would be the next step up so I
think there's probably going to be some
time before we would need to do that
um followup um Can Can you remind me
what the current population of
Manchester is it's
115,000 in change okay thanks thank you
yes thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question I
I as a selectman in my own town um we
think about how hard it is to get
volunteers uh to different boards and
commissions and we're so grateful when
when we do get them do you do you uh
could you see a situation where you just
might not be able to find seven
Representatives uh for these or six
represent
and not and and not solve the problem
that you are trying to solve or do you
know if there is that upwelling of
support out there that these seats would
be filled uh thank you representative
for the question uh I do know that uh
the the spirit of service within our
state and certainly within my community
uh I know that the mayor's office in
Manchester has a list of people that
have raised their hand and said they're
willing to serve erve on any number of
committees and commissions you know
within the city uh and I wouldn't
anticipate there being a challenge
filling uh the additional seats at least
in in Manchester not sure about NASA but
they've got a slightly less uh steep
steep hill de clim so to speak but I'm
I'm pretty confident that uh there are
some engaged citizens who would be
excited about the opportunity to serve
you thank you very much representative
will thank you for taking my question um
when I'm looking at the amendment I in
I'm I represent marac Hillsboro 21 and
we would go from two representatives to
four and when you because we have a
population of around 27,000 people um
and then you know when I hear you say
the addition to nasua
representation um I'm imagining in my
head these unwieldy commissions with
lots of people that are going to have
more of a difficulty reaching a
consensus
um can you tell me and I think
representative P this is kind of a
followup to his is what's the actual
size of some of these Regional planning
commissions for instance the Southern
New Hampshire Regional Planning
Commission or in my case the Nashville
Regional Planning Commission are we
increasing the representation by 10%
20% uh thank you representative for the
question my understanding is that
miramac is already entitled
to
let me just double
check
so I think they're at the 25,000
threshold as as it exists right now in
State Statute I'm almost certain that
Marram maac's entitled to four seats so
I don't think miramac is changing and
someone can correct me if I'm wrong but
that's that's my understanding when I
read the current statute um my
understanding is that the only cities
that would increase their
uh their representation on these
Regional planning commissions are
Manchester and nashwa uh and I can get
that information if you're interested in
uh learning more about the size of uh
the regional Planning Commission than M
Maxa thank you I'll check I I think we
only have two now but I'll I'll check um
myself but that that would be my concern
is that this amendment might create
these unwi de large commissions that um
just have more difficulty moving forward
on issues but thank you very much for
your commitment to representation thank
you addition question
yes thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking another
question um you've started me thinking
about
something that fortunately I wasn't
thinking about before now it's troubling
me which
is I represent LE Le Lebanon has a base
population of between 13 and 14,000
people but every single day seven days a
week we provide infrastructure and
services for upwards of 60,000 people
who work at Dart petock Medical Center
at the
University at the large Tech firms all
around
Lebanon how how would this formula help
a municipality such as Lebanon doesn't
meet the criteria for the population yet
must
support that those not similar numbers
of people with
infrastructure especially with an
infrastructure bill on the
horizon how would we how would we deal
with that how is that fair and Equitable
for a city like
Lebanon thank you representative for the
question and I I'm having a little bit
tough time hearing with the the air
circulation and so if I don't get this
answer if I'm not answering your
question please let me know and we can
take another another step at it um one
of the things that I've learned through
working on this
bill is that oftentimes municipalities
even if they have their two
Representatives on the regional Planning
Commission only one of them sometimes is
able to attend those
meetings um I think that the
way another thing that I've learned is
that there is a real commitment to the
region as part of these conversations I
I don't think any any municipality is
trying to Short change any others um but
I think
that and in hopes of answering your
question um I think the the more voices
that are in the room who can help to
share different perspectives on
challenges and and benefits of of
different policy proposals that come
through the regional Planning Commission
um the better and I think all those
those voices at the table fit together
like a puzzle that's the that's the kind
of visual that I've been working with um
I'm feeling like I'm probably not
answering your question so I'm happy to
take another stab at if you want to
repeat it I suspect it's an unanswerable
question okay I just wanted to put it
out there ether because is making me
think about other communities that have
this kind of population issue but
couldn't claim it as an issue
because the hosing isn't there to
support all those
folks thank you thank
you thank you representa as a reminder
if you are not
speaking who haven't been recognized to
speak please turn your microphone off it
helps to reduce the hiss that the
uh those that might be listening online
yeah are there any other questions from
the
committee
yes thank you chairman thank you for
taking my question uh I am a member of
the Southern New Hampshire plan Planning
Commission and uh as
such
uh I I find that your bill misses a
couple things uh we currently are
allowed to have alternat on on the
Planning Commission and I see that your
bill doesn't make any uh uh allowance
for that is this an oversight or is that
intentional uh thank you for the
question
representative I don't I I'd be curious
to know if alternates are currently
written into State Statute uh because
that was not something that came up in
my conversations with OS about this
bill
oh well I I follow up yes follow uh I'm
not really sure whether it's in the rsas
but uh you know I I do know that uh
there alternates because I was alternate
for a while you but uh uh my my that's
not really what uh I want to this is a
followup I'd like to ask about
uh the allowance for uh counties to have
representation on
the the Planning Commission this is
lines 14 and
15 of the amendment or the original bill
of the amendment okay do the uh do the
counties currently have representation
on the Planning
Commission uh I am unaware of counties
having currently having representation
on the Planning
Commission because I I I follow one more
uh because the uh the thing is like the
southern planning uh Southern New
Hampshire Planning Commission uh we
represent probably uh two or three
counties so that would be you know the
addition of say six more people onto the
commission and uh uh as one of the other
representative said you know this begins
to get a little unwieldy with the number
know so like I said it was this was this
something that uh was intentional to add
the the the counties to the uh Planning
Commission no
I there is no there's no intention to
add counties to the Planning Commission
I'm trying I'm trying to figure out
where in
the uh
it's it starts at uh line 12 and goes to
15 and says in any County or counties
which a origional Planning Commission
has been formed the County May by
resolution of its County Commissioners
become a member of said Regional
Planning Commission shall be atted
entitled to appoint two Representatives
commission
oh minut I have that was the original
Bill
okay but uh that verbage is is in the
21 the way that I read that and i' I'd
be you know we can get some
clarification on this is that
Representatives on the regional Planning
Commission they may be elected or
us uh of the municipality or the county
so uh each municipality is still
entitled to a certain number of
Representatives the county is not
entitled to any
it
representative me ask that before we get
to Executive session which probably
about three or four weeks but I ask you
to bring back to
us the answer about and substitutes
Regional Commission be
seated that seems like a rather large
hole for us
to Chairman just to just to clarify so
you're you're wondering about
substitutes and how they fit into this
okay thank you representative um we have
queued up also uh Mr Michael tarda who's
the executive director of the regional
planning
eff good morning my name is Michael
tardiff I'm the executive director of
the central man Hampshire Regional
Planning Commission thank you Mr
chairman and members of the committee to
have uh have me here today
um the regional Planning Commission is
uh headquartered here in conquer this uh
Amendment would not uh affect our
membership so uh basically for our
commission we have 20 communities all 20
are members um 19 of them the towns all
have two Representatives so there you
know and city of congr has
four the um the the message I wanted to
bring today from our association the New
Hampshire Association of regional
planning commissions as well as from our
commission is that uh we absolutely
support the the amendment to
to retain the the two the Baseline of
the two representatives for commissions
and you know comes down to the question
and and comment about volunteerism and
participation we uh We've we've had some
great runs with some of our
representatives for many years serving
our smaller communities two of them and
we really you know that was my first
take and I think the the first take of
uh the directors and and commissioners
of the smaller commissions that you know
have a lot of the you know base of our
commissions made up of smaller
communities to retain that that Baseline
of two I can't speak today to the
amendment related to Nash and uh and the
southern Hampshire planing Commission in
Manchester relative to the the proposed
changes I believe they executive
committees are going going to review the
the amended language and we'll be able
to come back with that but um I I did
want to say also that you know I I I had
my 22nd anniversary yesterday of uh
starting here here at uh Central
Regional planning and um I love when
when folks are talking about Regional
planning and it's you know it's near and
dear um I I did work for the uh the
southwest region Planning Commission in
my first job back in the 80s and and uh
you know
so spent a fair amount of time with uh
you know working on on Regional issues
and I I wanted to emphasize how you know
that that that that Regional cooperation
and and that approach is really I think
a Hallmark of the of the planning
commissions and you know some of the
conversations that we have relative to
funding whether it's the 10year plan uh
projects coming out of the 10 year plan
I think you know for our Planning
Commission we work very hard to find the
best
projects and sometimes the best projects
are unconquered sometimes the best
projects that year for the 10-year plan
are in dumbar or Warner and I think the
our our trans Transportation advisory
committee which makes recommendations to
our full commission I think has has you
know tried to to to follow that approach
over the many years that that we have
worked on these issues it's going to be
very interesting to see what the uh
infrastructure bill
means um and we really were learning
more about that all the time but you
know our experience has been with the
the 10year plan or the transportation
Alternatives program which is you know
the the rail trail projects the two
projects that came out of our region one
was in conquer for this last cycle one
was in
Warner uh followed closely by a project
that did not get funded we hope to get
funded and hop so uh I think there was a
lot of participation among all our all
our all of our commissioners and
um I would open it up if you had any
questions of me as a as a director of a
Planning Commission for but again a
rural Planning Commission which would
not be affected by by any of the changes
in the
amendment thank you well thank you Mr
director and any questions from the
committee yes representative gallager um
yeah can you just confirm your name
again for me I didn't quite catch it was
it Mike tardiff tardiff yes
okay
thanks it's tough with this uh very
filtered mask so Mr chairman
yes
thank you for taking my
question how many Regional planning
commissions are there in the state there
there are nine Regional planning comms
so uh four of them are are mpos
Metropolitan planning organizations so
more of the the the manchesters Nas and
then five rural planning commissions of
which Central Regional planning
commissions that's based upon Federal
designation for the uh Transportation
Planning process
follow up Mr chairman yes go
ahead for a
municipality that sits on the
edge of a of one
Planning
Commission but is affected by another
for instance I represent the Fairly
rural but Suburban town of
Lichfield which is part of the national
Regional Planning Commission but we are
adjacent to the airport sure in
Manchester so we're impacted greatly by
the
airport and maybe not so much by the
nashwa regional Planning
Commission and the reason I ask is
there's a lot of discussion about
Rail and ra
rail if it was to be
implemented would surely not touch
Lichfield because we have a river
between us and and the uh current rail
infrastructure so if there was a whole
bunch of money spent on
rail by the nashille regional Planning
Commission then witfield if I was a
member of the Nashville Regional
Planning Commission which I am
not but I would feel that we would be
left out by that but if there was
something going on with the airport in
Manchester then that would directly
impact us Mr representative I ask you to
try to turn that into a question yes
based upon your
experience uh how can the small town of
Lichfield make sure that it gets proper
representation and influence on both of
those you know it's it I think it comes
back to the the participation in the
transportation advisory committees and
the that that process specifically uh I
do know that there's an awful lot of
coordination between the nationville
regional Planning Commission and
Southern New Hampshire Planning
Commission you know on rail issues but
all Transportation all issues basically
um those boundaries were were drawn in
the 60s for the regional planning
commissions and I know that we have we
have spent a fair amount of time talking
about that sometimes with our our
commission our towns that are right on
the border and work very hard to to to
work with our adjacent Regional planning
commissions honestly I think it does
come back though to that just like you
know there that that process that that
Regional process to you know sometimes
there is a project that's not going to
impact a town directly but the next one
will so I think participating in the in
the process
continually um is is a way to kind
you
yes thank you Mr TARTA for taking my
question um there there were previous
questions uh POS I I I posed one of them
about the size of the commissions um
what is the size even though conquer or
the the regional Planning Commission
that that you're associated with
wouldn't be impacted by this bill but
what what's the size of the commission
how many so so we have we have 20 our
Comm our our commission is 20
communities so 19 of them have two
representatives and then city of conquer
has four okay so um if this and I do
have to say I you mentioned your tenure
in the regional Planning Commission uh
one of my first jobs was as an intern
for the Nashville Regional Planning
Commission summer of 76 I'm dating
myself sure but it was a great
experience assuming that some of these
commissions may actually expand by
several
members
um as an administrator how do you see
that being impacted at that
administrative level for just the
day-to-day responsibilities of the
regional Planning Commission office I
think you know there there there are
more seats at the table and um I think
administratively you know we work
closely with the staff of all the of all
the cities the and the towns that have
staff planning commissions actually
serve as a staff for some of the smaller
communities you know for our circuit
Rider planning
programs and even respective to the
question question about Lebanon I I know
that Upper Valley would work it works
very closely with the with the city
staff the town staff you know and all
the communities so um administratively I
can't really comment on it other than
the fact that there there there is
always very close particip or close
coordination between uh the regional
planning commissions the the staff of
the Cities as well as the the
Commissioners thank you any other
questions from the
comme
seeing none thank you director thank you
for having me is there any other comment
from the
audience
yes thank you chairman I just wanted to
um say that you know uh when the member
asked a question about uh County's
participation
um I need to do a little bit more
research on that piece um you know I
think your experience with regional
planning commissions you you you know
that counties participate and I think
that varies you know across the
different uh commissions so when I uh
report back to the committee I'm also
going to include some information about
the counties as well just so everybody
has an understanding of the makeup um of
each of these nine commissions across
the state so I just want to apologize
for not having that information right at
the at the top of my head and for
assuming the counties were not not part
of it you know I was reading further
into the statute and of course they are
if they elect to be part of thank you
very much we do have a couple of weeks
react okay seeing no additional comments
from the committee I'm going to close
we're going to open the uh hearing
1387 which is enabling municipalities to
exemption
I see you representative there do you
have a have you filled out a pink card
did
paper okay we have uh before US
Representative Reed who is a prime
sponsor the floor is yours thank you so
much Mr chair and thank you honorable
members of the committee for the record
my name is Ellen Reed I represent
Rockingham 17 New Market and new Fields
um and I I want to actually open I don't
know if this is appropriate I want to
open with an apology to your Vice chair
um I was asked to contact him and I
completely forgot because I have I've
had five major bills that I had to
introduce and I've been completely
swamped so I really apologize um um Mr
Vice chair um but I'm happy to talk to
you about this at length um
so uh HB 1387 which my co-sponsors have
uh affectionately named the freedom to
create a home act um I want to to start
by talking about two crises in this
state that I think everybody here is are
pretty familiar with the first is the
housing crisis um we have always for a
long time now have had a housing crisis
in this State uh where people um have a
difficult time finding housing within
their means but certainly that has been
exac exacerbated in the last couple
years uh by housing uh the housing
market inflating um the other crisis is
what is often referred to as the graying
of New Hampshire um the inability of New
Hampshire to seem to attract young
people or keep its own young people um
buying homes and creating you know
starting families in this state
uh so these are are two issues that get
talked about the gr of New Hampshire in
particular we we talk a lot about you
know different ideas of how to attract
young people sometimes you hear things
like maybe more theme parks or something
but we don't talk about the thing and as
a person who came to this state as a
young person um around the age of 30 I
can tell you what the thing is it's
housing it's it is almost impossible as
a young person to buy a home in the
state and most young people who are
freshly married or with their Partners
or however whatever life they're
choosing to live they want to buy a home
and New Hampshire is extremely
attractive I came uh to New Hampshire to
get my Master's Degree but um I wanted
to stay because it had everything I
loved Four Seasons mountains ocean
everything but my dream was to always
buy a farm I've had that dream for 20
years and to this day despite living in
this state for 13 years now I I have not
been able to buy a property and not
because I don't work or my husband
doesn't work but because whenever we go
and look at the market we see properties
that the mortgage is within our means
but then the property tax doubles what
we would have to pay on a monthly basis
so there is literally nothing that we
can get that we can afford because of
the property tax and that is not in all
a unique story that is the um experience
of almost every young person but not
just young people but those are people
that we want to stay here and buy homes
here but retired people who already own
their homes who can't afford to stay in
their homes or disabled people people
who are going through life transitions
whether they be divorces illnesses
especially right now with changes and
jobs um there are many many stories
where people cannot afford to either buy
a home where we obviously want people to
buy homes we we all acknowledge the
benefits of home ownership or or they
can't afford to stay in the home that
they've already purchased even in some
cases when they own it outright purely
because of property
taxes now as I mentioned property taxes
um a predominant cause of the first
problem the housing crisis one of the
main problems certainly we have the
housing market and inflation also to
look at but it is the predominant uh
cause of the the graying and making it
so that no property is is really
affordable and it's really sad because
in some cases people are taxed out of
their ability to just live and I think
it's kind of a human and I would even go
further I would say it's almost an
animal instinct to want to just have a
small corner to call your own a little
home to say I am safe and secure and
this is My Sanctuary no matter how small
or modest but that's a basic kind of
need so this this bill before you and I
I do have an amendment that um I'll talk
about how the amendment was formed in a
second but this bill is tax relief on
the people who we want most to have the
tax relief the tax relief on the young
people that we want to attract and keep
here and then the tax relief on the
elderly disabled people in transitions
as I've already mentioned who already
own their home so I want to very briefly
talk about um economics and tax Theory I
know that's a little bit wonky and dry
but please bear with me um in general
when we talk about taxes you might have
a percentage for a tax whether that be
an income tax of sales tax what have you
the idea is that the more you earn or in
the case of sales tax the more you buy
um the more you're paying because that
percentage in you know the percentage
stays the same but the amount of the
percentage represents the more it's um
the base of the tax is increased the
more the tax is right in uh absolute
numbers however that idea of taxing
everything at a certain percentage uh
does not take into account costs that uh
economists call inelastic inelastic
costs are costs that don't just grow as
your income grows but there there's a
limit to how much it can shrink as your
income shrinks so for example everybody
needs a certain number of calories to
live those calories cost money in terms
of buying food a gallon of milk is a
gallon of milk no matter how much money
you make you have to have food a gallon
of gas is a gallon of gas no matter how
much money you make there's a certain
cost to living that no matter how little
money you make you cannot shrink below
that cost of living it just doesn't
shrink with you so you start to get into
a place where you simply can't afford to
live that's in elastic costs of all the
inelastic costs that exist and this is
again economic theory um the one the mo
that is most basic uh after air water
and food is housing housing is not only
the most basic of our of our living
needs but it is also um the primarily
the largest of all of our expenses for
most people unless you're like a Jeff
Bezos person or
whatever your number one cost in life on
a month-to-month basis is usually
housing so it's really unfortunate that
that largest cost you have is also one
of the most
inelastic there is no such thing as $100
housing or a, home there's no such thing
as that it it only goes so low and then
if you can't afford the lowest there is
you're out of
luck so uh because housing is the
biggest expense for the vast majority
and is very El in elastic um
we but we don't have and so let me back
up with income taxes federal income
taxes for example you have U to account
for that um inelastic costs of of uh
basic living we have something like
standardized deductions right that's an
amount that the government says okay
this is a basic amount that you need to
just live we're not going to tax you on
the first 12,000 or 20,000 of your
income because you need that just to
live sorry was that like a I didn't
there was a sound um but we don't have a
standardized deduction when it comes to
property tax we don't give people an
amount that hey we're not going to tax
you on the first X number of dollars of
housing because you need that just to
live so it's unfortunate that the
largest expense that we have the most
inelastic expense that we have also
doesn't have any kind of deduction or
exemption so this is a tax structure
when you don't account for those
inelastic costs C that's a tax structure
that economists call regressive in the
sense that the less money someone makes
with that tax structure they are paying
effectively a larger percentage in
comparison to their living
costs um which means our current system
is actually taxing the very people we
want to give tax breaks to th those
young people and the people in
transition all those people that we want
to help out and make sure that they can
afford homes here we're taxing them the
most effectively in comparison with
their cost of
living so what do we do so this bill so
the history on this um for this
particular bill I contacted the budget
office they gave me a little bit of help
I spoke extensively over a few months
with the Dr Who were very sympathetic
and helpful but I really wanted a
mathematician right and I started
petitioning people online to uh
mathematicians to help me with this
because I'm not a mathematician I had to
sign off on the bill with my best
understanding from the people I talked
to to the with the at the Dr it wasn't
until after I signed off on the bill
that I was actually able to work really
closely with not just a PhD
mathematician but actually the chair of
the department he teaches at uh at the
college he teaches mathematics at um so
I have an amendment that tweaks this
bill in the way that the mathematician
suggested um and I'll go into the
details of that but essentially what
this does um is say that and this is an
enabling piece of legislation mind you
this is literally only giving
municipalities the option to to adopt
this if the voters in the town vote for
it taxpayers always for all property tax
issues the taxpayers are the ones that
vote on how the the property tax is
raised and how it's spent so this is no
different this is allowing the voters of
every town to say how they want to
manage their property taxes and what it
does do is allow them to adopt a an
exemption a homestead exemption Florida
has a similar homestead exemption um of
about 50,000 that's across the board
this has um you have to meet certain
qualifications to get this exemption so
for every resident in a town or every
household in a town that's below the
median uh home value in that town and
it's the only property they own and
their home or their uh household income
is at or below the median household
income in that town those people would
qualify for the exemption now my goal
was to give them a a basic living cost
exemption of half the median value in
that home in that town excuse me so if
the the average home value in New
Hampshire is 350,000 so if a town that's
an average Town U has an average home
value of
350,000 the idea is is that people could
get up to the first 175,000 of Home
provided they don't have an opulent home
that's over the average provided that
they don't have over the average income
and provided it's their only home could
get up to
175,000 uh the first 175,000 tax free
and then would pay taxes on the
rest representative excuse me
your demonstrated passion is certainly
admirable but if you could help me get
discussion to a point where the
committee can start asking you questions
so I'd appreciate if you could take a
look at what what else what other points
are very important for you to make and
then we can open it up to the committee
to ask you questions I appreciate that
and I am getting into more of the meet I
do have a chart this is more of the
technical details um and I realized that
this this particular hearing started
so also in the amendment by the way it
allow allows towns to adopt a 10-year
limit on the exemption so that any
particular resident would only receive
this if they wanted if the town wanted
to extend it to them for a maximum of 10
years and it changes the formula so it
still allows that half of the median
home value as an exemption but it is um
calculated by subtracting the home's
value from the median home value so that
there's no longer a cliff the way I had
written it before not being a
mathematician there was a drop off point
the new amendment makes it so there's no
drop pop off points so if the median
value is 350 and you have a
$349,000 home you get a $1,000
exemption so there have been other
attempts to deal with the housing crisis
um in the past we've all heard about
things like affordable housing projects
or Workforce housing um there are is a
Workforce housing requirement on towns
this is the opposite so affordable
housing projects are when the government
tells a developer you have to give a
certain amount discount to certain types
of people off the fair market value of a
home for them to buy it this does not at
all impact the market value everyone has
to buy a property at the fair market
value this has nothing to do with the
private Market this is literally getting
the government in terms of taxes off the
backs of the people who need to have the
breathing room in order to to engage in
the private housing market further
because there are Workforce housing
requirements on some towns towns can use
this in order to meet those Workforce
housing requirements without a single
development because this applies to all
existing homes you don't have to build
any new projects you don't have to touch
density you don't have to do deal with
any of those things that honestly not
only do people not want to see higher
density in their in their towns but for
the most part people who might have to
buy the the the these Workforce housing
don't want to live in high density areas
either it's not something that people
like most people want to buy a home and
communities all acknowledge that the
higher the home ownership is in a town
the more stability you have in that town
the more Goodwill toward between
residents you have in that town the more
investment you have from members of the
Town into the the town's workings so it
all um in enforces the idea that we want
people to own homes and people want to
own homes further when we talk about
affordable housing projects in Workforce
housing we're usually talking about
rentals so we it wouldn't be increasing
home ownership the way this would
be so here is the big deal how much will
it cost ah so I wanted to First say that
as a warrant article usually this would
have a tax increase associated with it
that tax increase would apply to
everyone who doesn't qualify for the
exemption right um naturally there are
other ways to pay for this I have a
little pet idea of every town should
start a thrift store and then you would
like take burden off your town dump and
have all these like cool things from the
town but that's beside the point one of
my co-sponsors said you could bond it
for the first year and just see how it
works but let's just say worst case
scenario the town has to in increase
taxes on those other residents that
don't get this
exemption when you do the math and we've
done the
math the increase is really nominal and
the reason the increase is nominal let
me just direct you and it was poorly
printed because it's very dark to the
first chart here this is a very average
distribution of home values in a New
England town uh the professor that I'm
working with actually teaches about
property values as an exception to the
normal random distribution when you
normally find a bell curve in nature
property values don't follow the bell
curve if you can imagine why let's say
your average home is 350,000 in that
town you might have homes like on this
chart 900,000 over a million you it's
impossible to have a home that's the
same value less than
350,000 as there are homes over 350,000
so there's no negative $500,000 homes
there's no zero doll homes and there's
really no $50,000 homes so there's a
steep drop off on the left and the curve
is skewed right and this is actually a
good thing and the reason it's good is
because it means your tax base for
everything that's higher than the
average your tax base is quite wide
which means you don't have to raise
taxes that much in order to recoup the
costs for the
exemption so when we do the math it
turns out and every time that we've gone
through these numbers you have to raise
taxes about 8% not points not points
that means if you pay $100 in taxes as a
person who doesn't get the exemption
with someone with an expensive home
you'll pay $108 in taxes if you pay
$1,000 in taxes you'll pay 1080 if you
pay $10,000 in taxes a year you'll pay
10,800 it turns out for a person who has
a home just slightly above average so a
$400,000 home if they're paying $8,000 a
year they'll pay
860 um or $8,600 a year which works to
about
$56 a month which is about the same as
taking someone out to lunch or maybe a
high-end lunch or a lowend dinner and I
would contend that if I can take one of
my neighbors out every month to lunch
and have that mean in exchange that
everyone in that town has the ability to
buy a modest little Home of Their Own
and have all of that investment and all
of that social cohesion that that home
ownership means I contend that that's
worth that lunch
especially for people who do have those
high-end homes and who don't are not
under the the average um
income but probably most importantly and
and by the way there's a uh a chart on
the back that shows you the exemptions
for each of the values in we kind of
created the theoretical perfectly
average New Hampshire town turns out the
average New Hampshire town has a th000
homes the average home price is 350,000
so this is using that average Town um
what you could see for exemptions versus
taxable
valuation but ultimately and I am
wrapping up right now um and there are
projections in the bill the select board
has leeway to adjust because the the
income it turns out the Dr said although
we have it's very easy to go on Google
and say what's the average um household
income in New Market and you can get an
answer that's you know well backed up
it turns out the IRS apparently the Dr
says the IRS has no um obligation to
answer questions to towns if they want
to know what the average household
income in that town is and so in order
to get over that hurdle that we couldn't
guarantee the IRS would communicate with
the town um we're leaving I'm leaving in
the bill a little bit of leeway for the
select board to adjust what that um what
they recogniz as the average income in
that town so if they need to they can
dial that down so fewer residents
qualify but all of the um all of the
graphs and and everything that you're
seeing in the
8% um those those numbers I quoted you
that's presuming every single resident
qualifies so finally I and I know this
is a new idea and I know new ideas can
be really scary but I know that also
what we're doing in the state just isn't
working Aeros Smith has a quote if you
always do what you've always done you'll
always get what you've always got and
that's kind of where we're at housing
has been unaffordable for a lot of young
people and other people who even bought
their home and are just paying taxes
only and still are having a problem it's
gotten to a situation right now where if
you need a home I could literally give
you one outright and you may not be able
to live in it simply because of taxes so
um I think we we need to stop nibbling
around the edges with like things like
you know small affordable housing
projects here and there and start to
really tackle the you know the the
reason some of the properties are too
expensive I'm fine with any number of
amendments as long as we're offering
substantial tax relief property tax
relief specifically to the people who
need it um and whoever provides that
relief in the state and therefore take
significant steps to addressing those
crises that I mentioned those people
will be heralded as Heroes I think
because that's one of the number one
issues in this state so thank you so
much for listening to all the technical
details and with that I will take
questions thank
you questions from the committee
yes thank you very much representative
Reed and thank you for taking my
question um on on your handout you have
a bullet near the Autumn it says all
property tax decisions rightly are made
by the taxpayers in the state um my
question is in in coming from a a town
of miramac where we get uh considerable
tax revenue from anheiser Bush and
Fidelity and Investments this would
increase their taxes and do you think
that increase in in property tax for the
industrial commercial base may be a
deterrent to having new businesses come
into New Hampshire in these
communities well so just like I said The
Wider the tax Bas the less the increase
and that's why you're only seeing a few
dollars increase I don't think so
because the more corporations the less
the burden again it's a very nominal
increase and it's still very competitive
with other states so I don't think that
it's it's an issue I mean the real issue
is that we're not competitive now in
terms of housing right that's the real
issue we can't get young people into the
state because we're really not
competitive when it comes to housing um
I'm glad you did point out that bullet
point because as you all know our entire
country was founded on the idea of no
taxation without representation right
the taxpayers have to be the ones that
make the decisions about where the taxes
go and how they're raised so I think
it's only right to allow the taxpayers
of every town to vote on this on their
warrant article do they want to see a a
less regressive structure or do they
not it's it's only fair to let them make
that decision follow follow up thank you
but um the commercial industrial the
little mom and pop shops that may be in
in town aren't voters so how would they
make how would they contribute to that
decision they they're paying property
tax but they're not voters in the
community so I I think that's you know
property tax right there there's there's
nowhere in our system and I would never
say that there should be anywhere in our
system where businesses can vote um I
would be vly against that so I don't
know if that's what you're trying to say
but it's it's already the case that
taxpayers in general individual people
vote on taxes that then impact
businesses that's just some of those
people who live in those towns are those
business owners and they have a right
just like every other person in that
town to vote for or against a different
tax
structure okay thank you any other
question
yes this is a very polite
committee thank you Mr chair and thank
you representative for taking my
question um I love a bill that that
challenges the thought and this and this
definitely does and I think your
Amendment although I haven't studied IT
addresses several of my questions but
one I don't one I think it creates is in
line
15 section three line 15 you say when
you're talking about the median assessed
value it shall be assessed for the
previous calendar year and this may be
just an opportunity for an amendment or
it may be a a defect whatever it is I I
just question that we don't do in
Northampton we don't do assessments
every year we do them according to the
every five years or in our case every
four years that we do them except for
the pickups is that an is that
intentional to do a calendar year or is
that an opportunity to just tweak this a
little bit what this is and specifically
that the reason and so I I am under the
understanding Municipal Association sent
a letter and they were concerned about
some of the vagueness in the bill um and
this amendment addresses all of their
concerns um they they specifically
pointed out what do you mean assessment
is it the value of the previous month or
is it the B value of the last 10 years
so I'm saying whatever the assessed
value was the previous year it's not
that you have to assess it every year
but wherever it was at in the last
calendar year is the number that you use
okay thank you does that answer question
you thank you uh Mr chair um and
representative um I I'm from NASA I'm
also a an alderman in in nashwa as well
um and I I have to admit that anytime I
hear about additional exemptions
additional credits my stomach goes into
a knot because I know exactly the people
that are going to be affected by and
that's the average citizen within the
city of Nashville now you keep talking
about towns I see this happening to
towns and to cities and in cities the
people do not vote for the the I didn't
know if you're aware of that they do not
vote for the the tax levels Etc um the
the alderman set the budget and the Dr
with the two other people set the tax
rate for the city
um are you m Mr chair if I may may ask
this question and um with another
followup are you aware of the the
current credits and exemptions for
Veterans for disabled for seniors for
blind for
um and are you aware of the cities that
give very large um deductions as it is
and nashille is truly just about the top
including over Manchester when it comes
to Veterans credits and so on I am aware
of the many municipalities that have
veterans disabled people a whole bunch
of different exemptions uh I believe for
most municipalities there is a an income
threshold that you have to be under to
qualify for them those this essentially
replaces that so it this doesn't add to
it I mean it adds to it in the sense
that it extends it to everybody
regardless of what their previous
occupation was or what their particular
health concerns are it extends it to
everybody who is in that same income
level that you're talking about and so
when you talk about affecting the
average people it is that's exactly who
I'm trying to help in this is helping
the average people so instead of only
helping people based on previous
occupation or particular health concerns
we're helping everybody who's in that
income uh the average working class
person who's in that income level who
just wants to own a home and contribute
to that municipality I am also aware and
I apologize for glossing over it that
cities don't directly vote on those tax
rates and of course we have this
representative system that we're all
familiar with that we vote for people
who are supposed to represent our
interests and so supposedly we we are
being represented through that um I
can't say speak to any particular city
as to whether or not the PE the will of
the people's action being represented in
any particular tax level but I am aware
of that so thank you I have a yes um I
I'm I'm trying to word this so as not to
to feel contentious because I believe in
in doing as much as we possibly can and
including to the point where Nash put in
inclusion area zoning which is not just
for rental it is for the sales of of
homes and so on um from multi multiple
units not single anything greater than
10 um but having said that um
the I I saw what your your
your chart showed but when you're
looking at a larger City such as
Manchester and um nashwa there would be
a a great impact on the
current uh makeup of those particular
residents would you not age read that
this could be quite the burden on some
that have already you made a comment
about $10,000 of taxes would only be
$800 and the example you gave I know
people who whose homes aren't all that
um expensive that are already paying
over
$10,000 and are over
$350,000 home so they would not fit
within that
$800 they can't afford a $56 every
single week do you not feel that that
would be a burden to these people well
again this is meant to help the people
at at the you know the middle and under
so if you're talking about someone who
has an above average home especially in
this market should be relatively easy to
to downsize but aside from that I mean
the great thing about this is that if
this doesn't work for any particular
municipality whether it's the city of
nasua and you all as Alderman already
feel like you're doing enough and and
you got the right housing balance worked
out in NASA and you've already got it
and you don't need anything else you do
not have to adopt this this is only
allowing this for towns that decide that
this is something that will help them
because right now as we all know we're
in a Dyan R State they are not allowed
to do anything unless we enable them
this allows them to adopt instead of a
on siiz fits-all tax it allows them to
adopt a tax structure that isn't
regressive thank
you
question
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question um
I'd like to ask a question
specifically I'm looking at your
Amendment
uh and I'm looking at the section in
lines 21 and
22 any municipality that adopts a
homestead exe exemption under this
section May limit eligibility for the ex
exemption to not Les than 10 years what
happens if this passes under this scheme
if in year three the person who's
claiming this exemption has a
skyrocketing
income what happen oh they don't call
it's a year toe qualification it doesn't
say
that it's all the numbers that it's
based on are literally the the previous
year's numbers so and you get taxed
every year right you you get you pay
property tax every year so that tax bill
which you have to apply for the
exemption right it's not automatic you
apply for the exemption through showing
your qualifications that year when you
get your bill then you get that
exemption so you have to show the
previous year's income the previous
whatever the level of your assessment
was for the previous year to qualify for
that Year's exemption so we all pay well
I I'm a renter but I also pay property
tax I just pay it pay it through my
landlord I also pay for Equity it's just
doesn't end up being My
Equity thank you let me just also say
that this
hasus over the years and inquired about
it TR to get
unus the terms City
municipality
Town Village municipality all in change
so if you have legislation that calls
out cities will do this means any of
them they're all in and and I use the
word municipality as an umbrella term
that includes cities towns Villages I
have you know I don't have an sb2 town I
have a Town Council town it's versus a
traditional Town there's all sorts of
different delineations and I just use
it thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question um
I want to follow up on representative
R's question about commercial properties
uh and and Industrial properties paying
more tax to cover these kind of things
and wouldn't those businesses leave to a
smaller town that has less of a
burden to another town that has less of
that would be putting less of a burden
on them to to match the budget that the
town has to come up well it's I mean
it's actually the case we already have
now every town has a different taxation
level so there are towns that may look
more attractive a few dollars this way
or that way I mean everybody's around
the 20s like you know mid 20 20s to mid
20s uh per thousand level but it's the
situation you have now where the people
of a town vote on what they want their
tax rate to be they understand that if
they increase it it increases their own
taxes it may you know be not is
attractive to businesses in their town
they understand that but they also
understand the benefits that they get
when they increase their taxes too so
every taxpayer that votes in their town
and I understand that cities don't
directly vote um votes based on those
issues and what they think the proper
balance
is but I think it's up to the it's up to
the voters to decide that
followup well as a followup um I live an
exor and is almost
million and or million whatever the
billion is um and we we give back uh
over $4 million in in tax exemptions
uh V credits etc etc that has to be made
up by all the other taxpayers so we've
seen this kind
of Homestead question before and I I
just have to keep
asking pay the the amount of money that
we have to pay for our infrastructure if
we're giving half of the half of the
valuation back
to I understand that as I as I shown in
the graph and in the chart the other
half the other half and that's that's
the decision that's the value judgment
that voters in a town have to make and
they make it every time they vote on any
tax property tax increase or program in
their own town um but what we're talking
about is not multiples of dollars on the
thousand we're talking about like I said
the difference between $100 and $108 and
is it worth it to the people of that
town and they have to make that decision
for themselves to go okay we're going to
pay a little bit more so that these
people can own homes and improve our
entire
Community
questiones
yeses thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for your testimony and your
excitement about about the situation of
housing which we
all are concerned about I'd like to just
say that I one thing I like about the
bill is it's
enabling but would you believe that I'm
a selectman in a small town about 10,000
people and I would never dare go before
them and ask them to accept this
concept because and we go before the
town every year it's com up in March and
would you believe that we have to ask
them for monies for certain things um
whether it's a school or a renovation or
what and it's not an easy sell and this
isn't something that uh we would be able
to sell and I don't want to shoot you
down because maybe there are communities
but I don't know where you're going to
find any communities in New Hampshire
that would pick up this concept and and
agree to uh go forward with it sorry to
say that but I think it's only fair no
and I guess then that means there's no
risk to passing it if nobody's going to
pass it on the town level then there's
no risk to passing it uh the the
question was would you believe and the
answer is yes I believe that I believe
every member on this committee is either
a a select board member or an alderman
or whatever uh local government level
and uh I guess I would say would believe
that I understand that a new idea put
before a whole bunch of
aldermen is is going to have a tough
time but I I go back to my original
point I get it's a new idea I get It's
Like A New Concept and it's you know
it's before a bunch of people who are
hesitant to adopt something new and
different but what we are already doing
is not working so we have to try
something different and I'm happy for it
to be something else as long as the only
things I've said is as long as it gets
tax relief to the people who need it
most that's it is there another question
re yes
representative thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question
uh my first question
is uh on lines uh 18 through 20 of the
dra of the uh
uh Amendment
Amendment the what do
you
believe the local governing body would
use as the basis for estimating the
medium household income of the
municipality thank you and I mean I'm
glad you brought this up because it is
me specifically giving that wiggle room
to select boards in in Alderman across
the state is my nod to say yes you you
have an ability to kind of uh control
this even if it's voted in and you
certainly don't have to recommend it
right it only needs to go to the the
town warrant it doesn't need to go with
a recommendation but to answer your
question um you can do a Google Search
and and find uh an answer to your uh
your town average income most of the
time you can get that from the IRS the
reason again I had the conversation with
Dr they said it the IRS is not guarant
to necessarily honor any requests from
towns for what their average income is
but certainly uh if you do an internet
research you will find a number of very
reputable sources that will give you
Town average household
income thank you uh yes representa a
question followup please all right go
ahead
follow uh lines 21 and
22 uh to deal with the uh eligibility
for the exemption uh you have a May here
instead of a Shia is that intentional
also it is intentional it is up to the
town uh whether or not they put a limit
on the exemption to say no one can claim
more than 10 years of this exemption um
or and they can they can limit it to 20
years or 15 years or whatever but they
can't if they want to limit it they have
to at least give it for 10
years thank you represent
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question it's a relatively
simple one um I would like to know
enabling legislation requires what is it
you excuse me any other questions are
speaking representative gu turn your
ahead representative
CLE thank you Mr chair and um I just
have one really quick question you made
a comment earlier that um this to enable
something like this we would kind of
more or less get rid of all the other
ones the seniors the disability and so
on but would it get rid of the
veterans do it doesn't get adds
exemption it doesn't take away any
exemptions but you're not getting double
exemptions right like so they're not you
can only be exempt once so it's not like
either just just a quick followup um
just more of a of a statement um
veterans do not meet a threshold they
just meet um a service connection um so
therefore like a surviving spouse um tax
credit for Nasha would be
$2,000 um a
AES reform okay so I guess I guess my my
qu my question is just that with your
enabling they would still be entitled to
the credit even if their um the value of
their home their assess value went down
they're still entitled to their veteran
credit unless the town decides that hey
we've just given this massive exemption
to everybody who needs it and then
veterans who are doing very well for
themselves don't need it and that town
decides to repeal that credit but that's
completely up to the town and this bill
doesn't touch veterans credits
represent any other questions for the
representative seeing none thank you
very much it's a long
topic uh we also have uh ready to to
nhma
thank you Mr chair this is I'm Nate GRA
with the New Hampshire Municipal
Association um I was just handed the
amendment so I haven't uh had a chance
to to read that or look at how IT
addresses any concerns that we uh that
we outlined in our letter that was
submitted to the committee earlier this
week um as written
testimony uh I will just say um briefly
that our concerns
were all about implementation we we
don't uh really oppose any sort of local
options um but in terms of implementing
and how this would actually function and
its relationship to other tax credits um
were our our major concerns and I'm
happy to answer any questions that
committee members may have the committee
oh
yes thank you for taking my question I
applaud the goal of
this but it seems very convoluted and
complicated do you see it that way from
the municipal standpoint I I agree um
because at least in the initial bill the
the term
typical wasn't defined as to whether
that meant mean or median in terms of
things like the typical assessed value
or typical household income um but even
assuming that you could assign that uh
it seems difficult to implement it just
on the basis of the rapidly changing
um uh residential Market as well as um
when you have instances of someone who
would qualify under the definitions but
then you know they qualified because
currently they are in a job training
program or a university or something and
then they get their degree and they get
the job that makes them a lot of money
um and therefore they no longer qualify
at what point do you of end the credit
for them and how does that work with the
tax cycle wasn't clearly defined within
the initial
Bill thank you any other questions from
the
committee seeing none I'm going to end
hearing
on on HB
1387 appreciate your patience this was a
long hearing uh so right now we're gonna
we're gonna recess for an hour give you
a chance to lunch and we'll reconvene at
one
o'clock Mr chairman yes my father was a
butcher and and whenever he was
butchering pork or beef they hung the
the carcasses in a very cold
room and I'm sitting here my teeth are
chattering and I have gloves on because
I don't have good circulation and I'm
just wondering if we could build a
bonfire or
something yeah we've had some
suggestions I understand that some of
you are a little chilly in the room that
my request to change the temperature was
shut down with the fact that this is now
a centrally controll system that local
uh controls no longer I see people with
their winter coats on it I thought you
you wearing gloves because you were
getting ready to take a long pass from
it my hands are
frozen sorry about that bring warmer
coat next time yeah in the future I will
johns
e
good afternoon this is uh House Bill
1397 we're going to look at and um it's
relative to the lent of terms for
Rockingham County
offices the sponsor for this bill is Tom
Dolan he's going to speak on the bill or
bill okay Tom thank you representative
Ponte House Bill
1397 is a bill relative to the the
length of
term that County officials can ser
to rocking H County this only This only
affects the attorneys does not affect
sheriffs or any other any other office
in the uh in the
county so I I'd ask you to to listen to
the various speakers they're going to
talk to this and I'll step aside to
allow that to
happen Okay
thank
uh thank you Mr chairman uh fellow
representatives for the record
representative Al baldau Rockin him
County District 5 which is London
der uh I'm on my eth term as a state
representative I stood at the polls many
times um with many friends on the left
and right and um it's at the point now
where when a county sheriff and I I
heard him say just County attorney this
is all I thought it was all the
treasurer the county sheriff the County
Register of Deeds County attorney and
rock andam okay uh but when you standing
at the polls and and that sheriff or
that depending whether you're a
Republican or Democrat they win the next
day they're out looking for more money
they're out um running for
reelection they don't run to make laws
they run to provide and support the laws
that we legislators make they're not you
know like the governor or state
representatives a sheriff has no
business running for
reelection okay the next day he's
elected for two more in two years he has
a job to do like for the first time in
my uh County we finally have a drug
enforcement unit we finally have
involved in school shooting you know
practices and things like that the
sheriff's we F we have a county attorney
that's involved in many cases and some
of them drag on the year two years uh
they're involved they're hiring they're
getting their counties up and running so
the counties should never ever be like
us as legislators or the governor or US
Congress or Senators because we all get
elected to make the laws um the
treasurer the same thing you know a
two-year job uh you know then why are
they wasting their time running for
re-election raising funds I don't know
how many times a sheriff asked re with
money I I just keep telling the check's
in the mail you know what I mean but he
he should be doing that the third year
or something after you know three years
of getting the sheriff uh organization
up and running and doing like he's been
doing finally in many years I've never
seen as many Sheriff cars out on the
highways now that you know doing a job
so they should be able to continue and
run for reelection every four years
which gives them enough time okay to get
the job done
this way here they're not looking for
money while they're trying to do a job
as a sheriff or a county attorney or a
Treasurer or anything on the counties
and that's basically where I'm stand
because I I think it's about time we try
to fix this here you know and this
benefits all of us Republicans and
Democrats and I think this should have
been a nonpartisan bill but I know it
was one of them bills that got was
rushed because the last one I guess got
table or something happen and that's all
I have and I'll answer any
questions
right representative okay thank you
representative bazaro my question is if
uh why is this bill just focusing on
Rockingham County and not all the
counties in New Hampshire I I honestly
think it should be all the counties but
Rockingham County Representatives took
the initiative uh your chairman and um
representative Thomas to put this in and
talk with the county and get there you
know and they supported it and was
pushing it but I think you got a great
question question it should be all maybe
Amendment could be done and do the whole
state because it's a
much
representa I see none thank you thank
you Mr
so good afternoon Mr chair members of
the committee my name is Kathy Stacy I'm
the Rockingham County Register of Deeds
a position I've held for the last 28
years I'm asking you to support I I did
send out the the the testimony that's
being delivered right now was emailed to
all of you in your legislative email
earlier this week so you know I'd like
to thank you for the opportunity to
speak um and I ask you to support House
Bill
1397 now although my position is elected
the functions of my position are
absolutely administrative in in
nature I have long believed candidates
for this position should be required to
possess knowledge of real estate
interests knowledge of significant
statutory requirements and possess
possess strong supervisory skills and
understand the budget process as you
know the only requirement is to live in
the
County elected County positions
territories Encompass vast numbers of
towns and cities requiring significant
time spent campaing we do not draft nor
vote on legislation we administer our
offices unfortunately even with the
enormous effort placed on meeting and
attempting to educate the public about
our positions if you ask many voters
about County positions they have no idea
what we do and that's really
unfortunate the current election cycle
scheme results in the official having
little over a year to focus on
objectives of the office with the
remaining time spent balancing office
oversight with a necessity to campaign
for
re-election it would be beneficial to
citizens to have more consistency in the
administration of the offices by
extending the term from two years to
four years this would enable the elected
official more time for long range
planning research and implementation of
new processes to keep the respective
offices up to date with current
trends as you know County Commissioners
enjoy a fouryear floating term and the
reason for that was for consistency in
the office because they run the county
all the other Departments of the county
so ensure that there's somebody there
who has some type of knowledge that's
that's already in in
statute I'd like to share with you that
the challenges in 2020 and 2021 brought
to the Forefront The increased
importance of focusing on daily
functions of my and the sheriff's
essential
offices you know we had to remain open
my office for Real Estate activity
because if we didn't what would happen
throughout the state would not be a very
good thing now I'll share with you that
50% of my staff was out for an extended
period of time during covid so I only
had 50% and we have seen incredible
increases in real estate activity
especially in Rockingham County I'll
share with you that I turned over
[Music]
6,645 th000 last year to the state of
New Hampshire and another 5.6 million to
Rockingham County my office is big
business and you need somebody in there
who is consistent and knows how to run
the
department the state campaigning or the
election during this past year was
challenging is to say it is an
understatement whether this year or
another election cycle the reality is it
is a distraction and I have an important
job to do a job that requires my full
attention it is a distraction not only
for the elected official but also the
public and my staff by anually staff are
expected to remain focused on the task
at hand but the reality is they fear the
unknown when it comes to elections the
what ifs can be debilitating staff asked
questions about Facebook posting
newspaper reports and become quite upset
when opponents come to our offices to
introduce
themselves you know our staffs are the
backbone of our offices absolutely
undoubtedly you know I I and I can't
stress enough how important it is for
any of us to have staff that are true
and loyal and want to stay in the job we
have enough problems right now trying to
keep staff just because of the
circumstances with covid I have three
openings that I have not been able to
fill in the last three years we cannot
get people to come and if we do they
don't
stay you
know in the long run obviously you know
as an elected official I know I have to
run I understand that I do it I enjoy
running for for election I I won't I
won't lie about it but it is a huge
distraction because the minute you get
elected know you may be working for
maybe about a year and then you start
thinking about gearing up because you
have to gear up I have 37 towns in
cities in my County that's a lot it's a
it's a big and it's a very wide area so
the final point I'll share is my
personal disappointments with election
results because historically if you look
at the ballots in any of these County
races you will find that people it's
like we fall off the ballot people don't
vote for the people at the bottom of the
ballot which are the county officials
and that's sad you know in closing I you
know again I ask that you support House
Bill 1397 I did provide to you because
last year when when this was heard there
was a lot of discussion during the uh
executive session with regards to you
know we if we give people a four-year
term we can't get them out of office and
that's not true because there is a
mechanism if somebody is not performing
the functions properly of their job
there is an RSA that allows the County
Commissioners and the
delegation to get rid of them so you
know I just want to point that out to
you so I I thank you very much for that
I'm going to end that testimony but then
I'm going to stop my new testimony so Mr
chair and members of the committee Kathy
Stacy I'm the legislative chair for the
New Hampshire Association of counties a
position I've held for the last I
believe six years so this past week you
know obviously we track all legislation
that's going to affect County government
this past week our executive board met
and I'm going to read a letter from the
association of counties dear chairman d
members of the municipal and County
government committee the New Hampshire
Association of counties would like to
register its support for House Bill 1397
relative to the length of terms for
Rockingham County of officers this bill
would increase the term length for the
Rockingham County's treasur Sheriff
register deeds and County attorney to
four years this would increase stability
and the elected offices for some of the
County's most important functions these
offices serve as part of the backbone of
County government New Hampshire and
reducing turnover in these positions
will allow for more long-term planning
and decision- making the association ask
for your support for House Bill
1397 and if you have any questions you
can address them to me or to Kate Horan
who is our uh executive
director thank
you testimony please uh would you accept
okay so um I was just
looking up the uh previous bill because
this was all sounding very familiar to
me um it was HB 560 right that um we
voted on previously about that and that
passed this committee didn't it what do
you know what happened to it after that
why are we having to it got laid on the
table uh at what at what stage that I
couldn't tell you all I all I can tell
you was that one of the problems last
time was that the sponsor was the finan
chair couldn't come and speak in behalf
of the bill and um I think that at your
executive committee I don't know that it
P I don't know that it came out of the
committee I'm not sure that it did I was
my um so yeah my or I was just checking
my own notes that said it um passed by a
vote of 11 to8 um and there's an
amendment to it that passed
unanimously so I was
wondering if you could explain the
discrepancy between our memories
here I I don't understand the question
well you you were saying you thought you
you were saying you thought didn't come
out of this committee I don't know
it's
uh thank you Mr chair um I'm going to
ask the the same question that
representative rung asked of a uh the
the previous speaker um would the
association do you think would be um in
favor of all of the uh counties going
with years versus just or have they not
discussed
this I no we really didn't discuss it I
know that the understanding was they
thought that this was going to be a
pilot to see how it worked in Rockingham
County and then go forward um and other
than that I really can't comment because
it's the executive committee all the
members that you know vote and this is
this is what came out of that meeting
was for support for Rockingham County
follow up just for
clarity okay so just so that I I'm I'm
clear you're you we're looking towards
it being a a pilot to see how it work do
you feel that if this did work you would
want to go forward with the other
counties absolutely okay thank you very
that uh thank you very much uh just a
quick couple questions Cathy uh in the
delegation we set the salary for those
elected officials how would that work
with a four-year term would
you you know obviously the delegation to
choose to do what they want years past I
can tell you that Mart County used to
put their elected officials on a pay it
would be like a pay scale just like they
do with regular employees so they would
move along that was what they did you
know so they set it always has to be set
before the sign up period and then it's
for the term whatever whatever gets done
is for the
question excuse me it says that it's
going to pass uh within 60 days if this
did pass say it's in June it's after the
filing period I think for those
positions so how would that
it that I I I couldn't tell you I mean
I'm not sure if it pass in 60 days I
mean I would hope it would be before the
sign up period but if it was after I
mean I don't know that you could just
say it's it's in effect and then people
who signed up because it wouldn't give
the opportunity for anybody else who
me so it talks about the general at the
2022 state general election and at each
general election thereafter will be
fouryear term so it says that this would
affect the 20 whe regardless of what the
timing is of the 60 days section
five says that it would be effective for
the 2022 state general
you thank you uh for taking my question
a question is you mentioned that this is
going to be considered a pilot program
before it's recommended for other
counties um has your Association
developed any criteria for evaluating
that pilot project what would be some
metrics you'd want to achieve in order
to make that recommendation I don't know
that it was our understanding of the
legislation that was put in was It was
supposed to be a testing or a pilot for
just Rockingham County that's something
that Mr Dolan that was the discussion
with Mr Dolan not certainly with the
association of counties the association
counties did not put this bill in we are
just supporting the
bill okay
um yeah thank you so the municipal the
the association of counties then but you
you're you're is it a formalized pilot
project that no no okay all right thank
not
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
members of the committee here I'm just
going to say as a co-sponsor I totally
support the bill and the speakers
previously behind me I also know that
the sponsor of the Bill of
Representative Dolan uh didn't in fact
mean all of the County uh elected
officials in in his statement uh
obviously uh we want to apply to uh to
all of those I also want to say that um
uh I in the the year years I've been
there out campaigning I see the county
people uh scurrying back and forth from
committee meetings to to events to
Coffee breaks and where they meet people
it takes away from their time and I
really think that the uh the four-year
um uh period is a good way for them to
actually get in uh you know do their job
that they were intended to do they're
they're not like us you know they're not
like the federal employees they they
have jobs to do so I fully support this
bill I also think that in in the recent
cases the costs of campaigning have have
really skyrocketed and this you know
adds to their costs as well and they're
not paid to campaign they're they're
paid to run the you know County as for
the idea of other counties doing this um
you know I think it's a it's a good idea
but I will say I won't speak for other
counties I think this is what Rockham
County would like to do if other
counties would like to follow a suit
they can certainly chime in or or uh uh
do what they want but but I I don't
speak for other counties so with that
said um I thank you for your time and
bill uh I don't sure if there's one or
two but I think A lot's been say here so
you
very good thank you um I like to start
out by saying saying i' I'd rather have
my my comments here as a discussion
rather than as testimony I'll certainly
take questions during any time uh anyone
wishes uh I believe that uh that
develops a conversation much better uh
I'm here today with basically with two
hats on over the last couple of days I
spoke with the other County attorneys
throughout the state either by video uh
or by uh email and I can tell you that
the uh that the County's attorneys
across the state 100% of us uh would
would wish an amendment would uh would
issue on this legislation to include
County attorneys throughout the entire
State uh we all believe that um that we
have a job that's
unique uh and it involves a great deal
of trust over a broad range and when I
say
that I mean we have to deal with dozens
and dozens of police departments many
many courts
and developing a working relationship in
a trust as County attorney takes time
within those
organizations um and uh the individuals
within the uh the multiple counties when
we're talking about the County attorneys
this is a bipartisan approach if you
want to look at it as a partisan issue
um both Democrats and Republican County
attorneys agree 100% that allow to apply
for for everybody uh Sheriff's County
attorneys across the state for
continuity reasons it would make sense
for it to also apply to other count
officials um but we do not um speak for
the other County uh County officials my
personal opinion I think it ought to
apply for Sheriff's County attorneys and
all elected County officials for a
four-year term um I mentioned um the
unique relationships that we have with
the courts and with the police
departments we have to establish that
relationship to set a tone and a tenor
of prosecution within the county uh we
have to have a continuity of operations
and a continuity uh of process uh that
exists between the many many departments
that we that we represent and that we
prosecute for in Marat County I
prosecute for over 30 police departments
when we add them all all up uh state
agencies local agencies fishing game uh
when you add them all up it's over 30 of
them uh it's very difficult for a city
and county attorney in two years to
develop the relationships that they need
to effectively um um interact with every
single one of those 30 police
departments marac county is a th000
square miles uh at its peak during the
day probably has 200,000 people in it
it's very difficult to interact with
those individuals in a rapid manner over
the course of a two-year period only to
start again the next couple years
regarding the election side of things
long range
planning uh I can only speak from from
somebody planning that I've done in
Marat County uh
I've tried over the last 12 months to
put together um what I'm trying to
accomplish with the police departments
of doing internal training to make uh uh
to give them training within our office
by attorneys so they can do their job
better it takes a long time to to
generate um the approach to that the
space for that uh to coordinate with the
uh with the chiefs of police uh and
that's doubly important from my
viewpoint as Marat County attorney
because the police departments now are
going from I believe it's going from 12
to 24 and going to 40 hours of training
time on an annual basis well I hope to
to do some of that within my office uh
and alleviate some of the burden on some
of the police departments especially to
smaller police departments when you're
talking two and three person police
departments relieving them of some of
the burden of cost of training uh is a
big deal and that's one of the
initiatives that that I'm trying to
accomplish doing that in that two-year
period um with the possibility that the
next County attorney uh may not follow
through with that with that organization
or that structure makes it very
difficult for continuity especially
within the uh uh within the police
departments uh attorney training is
another issue each County attorney views
attorney training differently uh I take
it quite quite seriously uh I've been
very lucky to uh be able to send several
of uh the assistant County attorneys to
some very good Training put on by the
national District Attorneys ass
Association 100% of my attorneys are
members of national District Attorneys
Association it's very important to
develop those those professional ties
different attorneys take a different
view on it and I again I think there
it that pretty much sums up my major uh
points that I wanted to make I certainly
will will ask for welcome any questions
answer any questions and chairman Dolan
if you are any other member of the
committee has any other information
information or any one any any other
information you can feel free to contact
good thank you um representative P Monte
thank you for taking my question thank
you so I'm really confused
by um what's already in the law what
that law covers and how the sections of
this bill fit in with with existing
law so as I read section
6531 it pertains to the entire
state it is not a County by count issue
pertains to the entire
state
um and then it goes on to say that those
officials appointed under elected under
this law include the County
Commissioners it doesn't
mention attorneys registers of registers
of Deeds so I'm just I'm hoping that
somebody can explain to
me how this fits into current existing
law uh how by Framing it as only
pertaining to Rockingham County we get
around the fact that
6531 pertains to the state as a
whole
um and so I'm just confused about the
structure I think I understand your
question when I'm reading the the 6331
Roman 5 change um 6531 I'm sorry Roman 5
change that was printed out the way I
read this uh it talks about uh uh the
first sentence not in bold talks about
which offices are affected the second
sentence indicates that uh that um
beginning in 2022 and at each subsequent
election Rockingham County is affected
by that four-year change when you look
at 733 which is above it beginning on
line two it talks about uh again uh the
County Attorney me members and then it
says provided that uh again in bold
provided that beginning in 2022 and I'm
paraphrasing the county attorney for
Rockingham shall be voted in for a
four-year term so the way I read this it
would only apply to Rockingham County
for the county attorney not
Statewide follow up if I may uh then
6531 uh why not make it just a bill that
cares out Rockingham County County
attorneys and other County officials for
fouryear
terms uh I have not um 6531 Roman 5 I'll
have to defer to the to the legislature
and your and your and the folks that
draft your your statutes and and uh uh
sub and and the submissions that you
submit only because um I don't know if
there's any interaction that I don't see
with with printed here and I'm not an
election law person but but I fully
understand my question but I understand
your question that if it was covered
under 7 colon 33 that it would apply to
everybody and would be and you wouldn't
have to do it under
65315 yeah that and that may be true
that may be true but without me doing a
deep dive into the other parts of 6 uh
6531 I I I wouldn't want to go out on a
limit answer that question because I
don't know what I don't know thank you
you
thank you um Mr chair um I just have a
really quick question um you you you
spoke to continuity um yes and I'm all
four trying to keep things on an even
Keel um you also mentioned about things
going into court and so on how long on
average and I know you probably might
not know this on the top of here but
does a court case last so for instance I
know you have attorneys that are
underneath you that are litigating those
but um as as the top dog so to speak you
would want to kind of keep control over
all of that so how long would an average
court case take and how often do you
leave things hanging if you were to
leave office I can tell you I just to be
Prov a little background for for for you
I've been practicing criminal law for
just over 21 years and as a prosecutor
just over 18 19 years um I practiced in
Superior Courts and bellnap Carol uh
Grafton uh meramac and district courts
about 11 or 12 about I think uh eight
district courts circuit courts um so uh
I'll speak generally about my experience
over those couple of decades misdemeanor
cases in the circuit courts uh violation
of misdemeanor cases may take three
months they could take a year and a half
depending on uh on um the posture of the
case the court scheduling uh obviously
I'm talking non-co issues here uh the uh
the uh it all depends on court on court
scheduling severity uh whether or not an
attorney changes in the middle of a
court proceeding so some could be fairly
quick some could take out take a year a
year and a half uh in the Superior
Courts some of the more serious cases
may may begin uh uh on day one and maybe
go on for two two and a half years um uh
I can't speak again I'm speaking only
for cases that would that the county
attorney's office would handle not like
a homicide case uh that the Attorney
General's office would uh would uh
handle I can't speak for their time in
time in court but there's quite a long
period of of time and remember for
continuity reasons too U there's a
continuity in approach to a case because
even before a case is is begun um uh a
case is filed uh with the courts there's
a lot of leg work that happens prior to
that with between the police departments
and the and the County attorneys or the
prosecuting attorneys I use the term
generally the prosecuting attorneys to
make sure that all the eyes are dotted
in Te across be be before we begin an
adversarial proceeding against the
person um so I think uh when you look at
Soup To Nuts you have to factor in that
that that preliminary time that's not
Court time in with it and some of those
so we're talking in some cases you'll
easily exceed year and a half or two
you thank you Mr chairman thank you for
your testimony I'm trying to get my arms
around uh what kind of longevity these
positions have what the track record is
are they being
reelected uh do you have any feel at
least with the County attorneys uh
whether or not the the longevity in that
position is the voter recognizing what
we're asking to do now to recognize that
this kind of a job does justify the
fouryear term instead of jumping in
every two years right right I know that
that some County attorne have served
several five six terms I'd rather not
mention who I'll I'll defer to them I
know some are in their first term such
as myself um you know and it's an
interesting question that you rais
because I think there's a there's a
there's a parallel analysis when you
look at the at the terms of service for
a county attorney the parallel analysis
would be the terms of service for a
police chief um and the police chief
term of service most police Chiefs have
in their their jobs for for several
years years it takes that amount of time
my opinion takes that amount of time uh
for them to to to I don't want to use
the term grow in in a in a in a bad
sense but grow into a job and develop
their their leadership uh style uh and
and the County Attorney has the same
thing uh I did a lot of leadership
positions when I was in the military I
did a lot of leadership positions
throughout life but the role was
different and um that first few months
you're you're feeling a position out
like any new position anyone goes goes
into even legislators I'm sure have to
feel out how they enter their their
individual jobs um so I think the
continuity is there I think citizens
sometimes recommend sometimes recognize
that and and choose to elect their their
their County attorneys just for that
reason and there are several County
attorneys I I assume more than two that
have been in their positions for quite a
long time and that the that the
residents realized that there was a
benefit to that
continuity would you believe that uh I
only can talk from Rockingham
County you know you don't allow could I
[Laughter]
a
understand yes thank you Mr chairman
sorry about not asking a followup but
would you believe I can only speak for
Rockingham County but I'm sure all these
positions have longevity have a history
of being reelected reelected yes unless
there's a an opening is very seldom so I
think the voters in Rockingham recognize
the fact that whether it's a twoyear
four year or sixe term they want these
people who are providing these kind of
services uh justify coming back and
doing their job so and I'm quite sure
it's sure in the county ATT yeah I I I
can't speak for the other counties and I
didn't do a deep dive into the number of
years individuals have been in their
jobs so I I couldn't comment beyond what
I just said thank you yes sir thank you
Mr
you good afternoon my name is Chuck
beses and I'm the Rockham County Sheriff
uh thank you for letting me speak to you
today um I'm on my second term as
Sheriff um I took over after um my Carol
turned 70 years old he couldn't run for
Sheriff um in my three years as
sheriff or when I ran for a sheriff I
used to say that law enforcement used to
change every single day but law
enforcement changes every single minute
with all the LEC reform and everything
going on in this country um just one
example our training this year is going
to 24 hours and that doesn't include the
extra hours we're up to over 45 hours uh
per year in training to keep our
certifications as police officers I'm
also a business owner in London in New
Hampshire I've been a business owner for
over 40 years and I've been in law
enforcement for 33
years when I took over Sheriff my main
goal was to become a community police
organization where we work with our
local state and federal law enforcement
officers throughout the
state my biggest passion was
drugs in my three years term I've taken
the drug unit in Rockingham County
through granite Shield I have 20
officers that this pays for their
overtime have enhanced our drug unit to
seven deputies that are in that to go
out and fight this Dangerous Drug that
affects our family F family F uh family
friends and and
friends um but it takes work as soon as
I get elected to sheriff my first term
which was very expensive it cost me
close to
$40,000 to run for a two-year term I'm
back running again with everything
that's going on with law enforcement
everything that's going on in this
country it's hard for me to try to keep
up with what I'm doing when I have to go
out and Camp hand again and raise money
I have to agree with the register ad
Deeds when it comes to County officials
and I think we all feel the same during
a presidential election we were actually
on the back of the ballot in Rockingham
County so people didn't even know that
they were County officials because a lot
of them didn't flip that ballot
around it takes a lot of work for what
we do and you know two years isn't
enough it you know it I've taken the
sheriff's off office from a good
position and I've I've vetted the whole
organization where we work together with
our local state and local law
enforcement officers and to try to
concentrate on running a campaign every
two years because as soon as you get
it
thank
you
bill
as
I want to thank you all for some
understanding on that last bill I got
something backwards for some from some
notes I had I apologize I think the
speakers fixed that in the discussion
so just more making aware of that my
apologies hey the the last bill we're
going to speak to
today is House Bill
1277 which is relative to the reping of
SES uh do we have someone to introduce
yes thank you Mr chairman uh and members
of the committee uh for the record I'm
represented Peter ssuch uh District 7 uh
Rockingham and WT Smith welcome thank
you um this bill uh result is the result
of a conversation I had with our it
commissioner Dennis GLE when I asked him
if there's something that he thinks is
is of high priority in his mind that he
thinks we should have a bill for and he
said currently his number one worry and
concern is the is issue of cyber
security incidents but specifically he
mentioned that one of the concerns he
had was that
currently um the many uh municipalities
uh use their computers to connect to
State computers for various
services but if those municipalities
encounter a cyber security incident uh a
hack or a A ransomware or anything like
that they are not required to report
this to his
Department which means that there could
be a potential for State computers to be
indirectly hacked or taken Ransom
through the connection with
municipalities so this bill basically
says that when a municipality encounters
these kind of problems on at their level
if they are doing business with the
state which almost all of them are that
they are required to report this to the
it commissioner that's pretty much very
simple uh way of stating it now um in
the meantime I received a a letter from
the municipal Association who points out
that the way this bill is written
currently it could imply that any
incident occurring in that municipality
would be reportable uh and so they
suggested a change a small minor change
to the bill let me just mention that to
you
um on
line line four and five where it
says um suspects a suspects a cyber
security incident within such political
subdivision uh here they're saying uh
the municipal Society Society uh
Municipal
Association uh says this could imply
that it's any incident within that uh
subdivision and it could be a private uh
incident with a business or a residence
so they suggested a minor change saying
um that suspects with a a a cyber
security incident within the political
subdivisions information system that was
the intention originally of of of the
bill and that just specifies it's just
concerning those uh information systems
of the municipality and not anyone
anyone's personal or business computer
uh that's that's pretty much all I have
in the way of detail here but I believe
that commiss uh commissioner goule is
here to answer more details but I'm also
willing to answer any other questions
it's just uh pretty much it's a very
straightforward Bill thank you
representor let me ask you a question
would you consider a fill on the blank
type of report where the intent of that
would be to truncate the amount of
reporting to be done so that in spot you
don't have a two-line message and other
spot you have a two-page message would
you consider some type of a fill-in-the
blank
report
um uh I personally find that a
reasonable suggestion uh but I would
definitely defer to uh commissioner GLE
on on the details of anything like that
any other questions to this
witness it's commission oh
ahead thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question
uh I saw this and I thought right
away
uh why do we need something like this I
would think that uh the uh State
information manager or whatever they
call it would uh would have this as a
regulation within uh uh or a policy
within his her viw rather than you know
having another law what are what are
your thoughts on
that well my understanding is from my
conversation with commissioner gule is
that he doesn't have that Authority at
this point and the other thing worth
pointing out is that many
municipalities in our state don't
necessarily have the expertise on site
of their own to sometimes troubles shoot
serious problems but if gu if
commissioner gay is not involved in that
then that could put the state's
computers at risk follow up yes follow
um well in my mind
uh the towns or municipalities informing
the the state about this would be uh the
Catalyst for uh the state taking some
action so it's one of these things that
uh the important thing is that the state
is notified you know yes and uh I still
believe that uh it would be better to
have a regulation or a policy at the
state level than than another law but uh
your
thoughts thank you uh representative for
that question I still I totally agree
with you that would should be adequate
but I still want to defer to uh
commissioner gay to answer that in
detail because he's the one who has to
deal with this issue thank
you yes Diane thank you Mr chairman and
thank you representative for taking my
question to date are you aware of any
incidences or examples in which this
legislation or Bill if it were passed
would have helped um a political
subdivision in there for the state so my
question is are you aware of any um
recent situations thank you thank you
representative for the question I
uh I'm not specifically
uh aware of an incident that happened in
our
state as far as what how what the
engagement of that municipality was with
the state of course we all heard about
what happened in perville where pretty
much their computers were locked up or
taken ransom for a while I don't know
whether the state was involved in
resolving that issue or not uh again
like I said I don't have that personal
information that uh commissioner guay
would have but uh I would think in that
situation there might have been
Assistance or help from the state could
help them quicker resolve their issues
but I I encourage you to ask the
question to commissioner gule any other
questions San is the commissioner here
would you like to come up
commissioner yes if I may um could I
just do a brief introduction oh and then
um I you know I think I can help with
some of those questions as well um my
name is Dennis goule I'm the
commissioner for the Department of
Information Technology the state of New
Hampshire
and we I support this bill for three
reasons um one is um in the event that
there is an incident we're pretty aware
of what the resources what resources
exist state and federal level um that
can help out when these things occur and
we've seen multiple instances where the
the political subdivision was not aware
of what could be brought to bear to
assist them so that's one helpful thing
and we have seen direct evidence that
that's you know once we become aware um
we've been able to
help with um you know the uh direction
of
resources um the second reason really is
situational awareness if you've followed
the news over the past few years you've
seen some states where multiple
political subdivisions have been hit
with ransomware or some other attacks
all at the same time so it would be
really helpful you know if we know that
something's going on in one place uh
that situational
awareness to help make sure that we're
alerting all the all appropriate
authorities and all folks that could
help so that if it happens in another
place the response can be triggered
faster one of the rules about cyber
incidents is that the more quickly you
recognize it and respond to it um the
less likely it is to be severe and then
the third um reason is the one that
representative ssuch brought up which is
that you know we do connect to these um
entities for a couple reasons Town
clerks for processing DMV transactions
as well as law enforcement for the the
the research that local law enforcement
entities do as well as um other other uh
things that are done from a law
enforcement perspective so that that
concludes my formal testimony I could go
into a couple of the questions right now
and then we can take as many as we need
question thank you Mr chair and uh thank
you for taking my questions but uh it uh
it seems that uh if you are you have a
connection with the uh the
municipalities uh uh information systems
that you you would have some sort of uh
rules that that guide or govern that
connection and uh I would see this as
nothing more than another section within
that guidance on uh what to do should uh
a cyber security incidents happen is
this
correct um I'm not I'm not aware of of a
set of rules Associated that we we make
recommendations on how they should
connect and we um we give them different
options for connecting but it's it's as
simple as that we don't put we have not
imposed rules on how they operate their
own um their own networks in fact I
don't think we'd be able to do that that
would that would drive cost into their
operations by us PR gating rules because
we would probably expect things to be
stricter and we know that we operate our
Network more strictly than than does um
many or most of the
municipalities follow follow up please
well it would seem to me that uh if you
could provide some guidance on how they
should operate their networks that would
be cheaper than uh
the cost of implementing some
things that in a form of a question all
right I I believe that
uh uh it would be cheaper for them to
accept guidance by you than it would be
for them to find out later that they had
an incident is that correct that's
correct in fact we are working closely
with uh the nhma municipal Association
as well as primex to work with
municipalities to advise them on how to
secure their own
networks um using a set of uh controls
that are prom promulgated and are
standardly used around the world called
the CIS controls so primex has been you
know we we've been working with primex
to make sure that what they're asking
their they
customers is the same thing we're asking
for so that we're not making them to to
do different things and you obviously we
have different interests primex is it's
loss control right they they're the
liability insurer we're the folks who
want to keep you know continuity of
government through our you know Citizen
Services through keeping the systems
running so we have we are aligning on
that and that is absolutely a prime
yes um I notice on
um line
um five it talks about when they
discover the
incident they shall report it
immediately uh should
we I understand what immediately means
but let's say they discovered at the end
of the day on
Friday and they I mean uh uh and the
town clerk has already gone home for the
weekend should we should we be more
specific than just saying
immediately um well when they presumably
in in that example that if if something
happens over the weekend which is
actually quite possible and even likely
because our the criminal actors uh tend
to try to time things when they think
they'll be optimal like during a holiday
or weekend or something like that but in
that case they wouldn't be they may not
be aware of it till Monday so they'd be
in compliance but I will also O say that
um time is of the essence especially on
ransomware um for example um in in
200 15 when I joined the state we had a
a well-contained ransomware incident
that um in in the executive branch that
um was able to Ransom
150,000 files in less than five
minutes so um so timing is pretty
important important and and and it's
really easy to report that was another
question that came up we have a 7 by 24
line that takes calls um so that
essentially the process is during the
day if what if somebody were to call
that line and report a cyber incident my
staff would take the call they're
classified state employees in the off
hours those calls drop into State Police
Dispatch they have a script for handling
them I would get the call 7 by 24 so we
have a we have a 7 by 24 capability
there to to catch a call to respond to
it to look not only to assist um if we
can and and we have done that I've done
that in the middle of you know late late
at night for political subdivisions
there was another question had you know
is there is there practical benefit from
this yes there has been I can give you a
number of incidents although the you
know I would want the political
subdivision themselves to it's their
private information about their system
so I wouldn't share it in a public forum
but um um you know certainly we have
several examples over the past five
years where we've you know the state
government has been able to assist and
and uh and or leverage Federal resources
or private resources like primex to help
them
out thank you thank you Mr commissioner
any other questions for the commissioner
yes thank you Mr chair and thank you
commissioner and representative for
taking my question because I think it
might go to both of you but I'm not 100%
sure I'm thinking of an incident that
happened in Northampton the town that I
represent a couple of years ago where we
were uh we were the victims of fraud we
immediately reported it to our it vendor
and we took the the necessary
precautions actions that were required
so I'm just I just want to understand
then if this were to be implemented and
I certainly think it's a good idea what
would have happened then would would the
St would your role be that one of a
Cooperative with us would one Trump the
other um I'm just trying to understand
because our we we contract a lot of
money with our vendor but if you know
the state's not charging us for it you
know maybe we go to somebody like the
nhma and say we'll take your legal
advice rather than go to our
attorney well that that's a good
question and it goes to a a previous
question um so U my authority in in in
our enabling legislation RSA
21r um is restricted to the executive
branch
state government so I I would have no
Authority and probably should not have
authority over um how I a political
subdivision responds to a uh a
Cyber attack so in the case you guys did
a great job I was aware of what was
going on and you know you responded
quickly we you know the um generally the
in an incident like that all we did when
once we found out was make sure that all
the appro resources no whether it was
the you know Financial crimes division
for the Secret Service or the FBI or
primex but sometimes primex finds out
and they tell us and sometimes we find
out we tell primex and we Loop the right
authorities in so we would take a a we
would stand by to help that's typically
what we do some sometimes we have helped
a lot other times we've said hey you
know we're pretty good um and then we
might if it's ransomware we might
disconnect that connection until we know
we've secured it because we don't want
to have those that that
ransomware flow into the state Network
and start taking State systems down but
um does that okay but I don't have a lot
of extra money we so we and we do have
some Grant funds that um were recently
um appropriated through accepting expend
fiscal committee that is targeted 100%
at municipal cyber security which I'd be
happy to share but I don't want to take
time up for this committee thank you
commissioner thank you gentlemen oh
sorry one more
comment thank you Mr chair and thank you
commissioner for taking my question as a
freshman state representative I'm not
familiar with the term that any vendor
acting as an agent of the political
subdivision do you help me to understand
what a vendor would be thank you sure we
have you know the our political
subdivisions are of all shapes and
colors in in New Hampshire and
particularly all sizes right so you have
fairly large cities then you have these
teeny weeny you know little entities
sometimes less than 20 people comprising
them and the way they manage their it
function is very different so some of
them have some IT staff who actually
support their information technology
needs and others have no it staff at all
and it's a town manager who manages a
what we call a managed service provider
or MSP and then that entity actually
runs their entire it function and and
that's why we put that um language in
there because it is very prevalent
particularly for the you know the
smaller entities in the
state thank you gentlemen appreciate
last person to testify today will be
Margaret burns from the
nhm
sorry about that good afternoon I'm
Margaret burns the executive director of
the New Hampshire Municipal Association
um thank you uh nhma does not have a
position on House Bill 12 77 but we have
been talking with commissioner goule now
I think for a couple years about
legislation to this effect um and the
Department's interest in having
legislation that would have
municipalities report cyber incidents to
the Department of Information Technology
really our only comment on the
legislation is the amendment that
representative somuch spoke about a few
moments ago that would be lines four and
five changing the language from cyber
incident within such political
subdivision to within the political
subdivision information system and the
need for that is I could see this being
interpreted to mean that any cyber
incident occurring in the geographical
boundaries of the municipality would
need to be reported and of course that's
not the intent of the legislation um so
that's our only comment on the bill and
that is what we would ask be amended if
the legislation were to pass pass um and
those are my comments on the bill but
I'm happy to take any questions that the
committee has let me do some real time
questioning Two Gentlemen representative
the Commissioners would you be
interested in taking that advice to make
that
Amendment okay I'll put it in your
responsibility to give us that Amendment
will be about three
weeks thank you any other questions for
just real quick could you spell your
last name for us just um for note taking
purposes sure it's B yr
NES okay thanks thank you okay thank you
everybody uh with that we're going to
1277 and uh that finishes the work for
today
Monday next no not next Mond yes next
Thursday I'm
sorry sorry a week from today next
return
I'd say within a week 10
you
sced
yeah I I must been reading from an old
that
yeah
think
more
having
right
own
police
protu